Now I'm back and finding that I'm not writing code anymore, which is an existential crisis for me. For me, this, you know, hit pretty hard because Dave Abraham's, who was a member of Software Technology Lab on my team, he really had a pretty strong reaction, anti-AI reaction. And I was like, you know, this is going to destroy the industry. I have done very little with the book because who's going to read it? Right, right. What's the point? AI is going to be a bigger change.
现在我回来了，发现自己不再写代码了，这对我来说是一场生存危机。对我来说，这，你知道的，打击相当大，因为Dave Abrahams——我团队里软件技术实验室的成员——他对AI表现出了相当强烈的反对情绪。当时我就在想，你知道的，这将会毁了这个行业。我几乎没怎么处理这本书，因为谁会看呢？对吧，对吧？有什么意义呢？AI将带来更大的变革。
And I think just saying, you know, I don't want it, I don't like it, is not a productive stance. And start to think about what is the role of people in society where we are no longer the most intelligent thing on the planet. You know, right now I think our politicians and leaders are woefully ill-equipped. I don't think they have any idea of what's coming. I think we just have a small glimpse of what's coming. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 300, recorded on August 19th, 20206. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we celebrate our 300th episode by catching up with Sean Parent since the last time he was on ADSP at the tail end of 2025. We chat about AI, how Sean isn't writing code anymore, how it's affected his workflow, its implications for society, and more.
我认为，仅仅说“我不要，我不喜欢”，并不是一种建设性的态度。我们需要开始思考，在一个我们不再是地球上最聪明生物的世界里，人类在社会中扮演着什么角色。你知道，现在我认为我们的政治家和领导人极其缺乏准备。我认为他们根本不知道即将发生什么。我觉得我们目前只是窥见了即将到来之风暴的冰山一角。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 300 期，本期节目于 2026 年 8 月 19 日录制。我是 Connor，今天与我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，通过在 2025 年底上一次做客 ADSP 之后再次邀请 Sean Parent 叙旧，来庆祝我们的第 300 期节目。我们聊了聊 AI、Sean 如何不再写代码、这对他的工作流有什么影响、它对社会的意义等等。
Wow. All right. We should. Will that make the final cut? Maybe, maybe not. So I guess, yes, we should launch. Should I actually share? I wasn't sure if I was, I launched it in case.
哇。好的。我们应该。这会剪进最终版本吗？也许会，也许不会。所以我想，是的，我们应该开始了。我真的该分享吗？我不确定我是不是在分享，我把它启动了，以防万一。
Maybe this is a good way to start. I see, Sean, you've got your, you've got your CPP concert. I was just thinking earlier about what I'm going to do with all of my conference shirts. And I have this, my dad used to be a windsurfer. And he would go to all these windsurfing regattas. And my mom had this quilt made. from all of his t-shirts that I had as a baby. And so I was thinking about something like that.
也许这是一个好的开始。我看到，Sean，你穿着你的，你穿着你的 CppCon 文化衫。我刚才还在想，我要怎么处理我所有的会议文化衫。我爸爸以前是个帆板运动员。他会去参加所有这些帆板帆船赛。我妈妈用我小时候穿过的他所有的 T 恤做了一条拼布被。所以我在想类似的事情。
But I have so many conference t-shirts, it would be like 12 quilts. But then I'm thinking I have this big white ceiling above me. If I could somehow attach the quilt to the ceiling, that would be super cool. Or make like wallpaper out of all my conference shirts. It would probably be pretty easy just get some wood frames and then stretch them out and staple them to the wood frames. and then just tick those a lot easier than having a quilt made. Yes. Knowing Bryce,
但我有太多的会议 T 恤了，做出来得有 12 条被子。不过后来我在想，我头顶上有这么大一块白色的天花板。如果我能想办法把拼布被固定在天花板上，那一定超级酷。或者用我所有的会议文化衫做成壁纸之类的。弄几个木框，把它们撑开，然后钉在木框上，可能就相当简单了，然后再把那些……比让人做一条拼布被要容易得多。是的。了解 Bryce 的话，
he is going to contract someone to get that quilt made, though. A lot of the same, and it would also, you know, cut down on your echo. Yeah. Yeah, that's true. He's got a pretty good mic, though. But what I was about to say before that was here, I'm going to share an entire screen.
不过，他肯定会找个人来定制那条拼布被的。很大程度上也是这样，而且它还能，你知道的，减少你的回音。对。对，没错。不过他有一个相当不错的麦克风。但在这之前我想说的是，在这里，我要分享整个屏幕。
I've been teasing this for months now, but seeing as it is a special episode 300, we've got back the most recurring guest of all time, probably the most asked for guests of all time, Sean Parent. And speaking of Sean Parent, hopefully I'm sharing the right screen. This is still yet to be released,
我已经拿这个开玩笑了好几个月了，但既然这是一个特殊的第 300 期节目，我们请回了有史以来出现频率最高、可能也是呼声最高的嘉宾 Sean Parent。说到 Sean Parent，希望我分享的是正确的屏幕。这个功能还没发布，
but this is an emulator version. I mean, I've been using it since February, however many months that is. But every single time I have a new idea, you know, I just keep on adding it. And this is a podcast player, podgod, soon to be released on Android, and then after that iPhone.
但这还只是一个模拟器版本。我的意思是，我从二月份开始就一直在用了，管它过去几个月了。但每次我有新想法时，你知道的，我就不断地把它添加进去。这是一个播客播放器，名叫 podgod，即将率先在 Android 上发布，然后是 iPhone。
But the beautiful thing is here. Sean and Bryce are looking at this. We've got ADSP, of course. But then we've got one of the many personalities that you can go and subscribe to. What is a personality? It's like a meta podcast that curates all the interviews across all podcasts. So if you click on Sean, obviously we have on almost Monopoly on interviewing Sean. And I guess episode 300 is going to be here when we release this on Friday.
但美妙之处在于这里。Sean 和 Bryce 正在看这个。当然，我们有 ADSP。但然后我们还有你可以去订阅的众多个性频道（Personalities）之一。什么是个性频道？它就像是一个元播客，策划了所有播客中的所有采访。所以如果你点击 Sean，显然我们几乎垄断了对 Sean 的采访。我想当我们周五发布这期节目时，第 300 期节目就会在这里。
We're recording this on Wednesday. How does this work? So is this? Wait, wait, wait, before we have questions, if you scroll all the way back, The first, I'm not sure. So I actually, when I was communicating with the AI at one point, I was like, you know, and if we're lucky, well, actually, I'll discover some interviews with Sean Parent that I don't know of, but the only ones that came up with were the ADSP ones and then two CPP cast ones and then a CPP chat,
我们是在周三录制这期节目的。这是怎么运作的？所以这是？等等，等等，在我们提问之前，如果你一直往回滚，第一个，我不确定。所以实际上，我有一回在与 AI 交流时，我说，你知道的，如果我们幸运的话——好吧，实际上，我会发现一些我不知道的关于 Sean Parent 的采访，但唯一弹出来的只有 ADSP 的那些，然后是两次 CppCast 的，还有一次 CppChat，
which is a now retired or deceased podcast. And it's pretty fantastic folks. So I would say it might be out by the time. You're listening to this, but that's not true. I checked. And it typically takes one to three. sometimes upwards of a week for Google to approve apps. And to be honest, there's a couple things I'm still trying to add.
这是一个现在已经退役或停播的播客。各位，这真是太棒了。所以我想在你听到这期节目时它可能已经上线了，但其实并没有，我查过了。通常 Google 审核应用需要一到三天，有时甚至会长达一周。老实说，还有一些东西我仍在努力添加。
Anyway, so if you are a listener, and this is going to kind of undermine the point of trying to grow our listenership, if you actually are only here for these Sean Parent interviews, you will be able to go and unsubscribe from ADSP and just subscribe to the Sean Parent personality. And anyway, so. So I have a question. How does this personality feature work? Is it AI powered or do you somehow index guests? Is there some way to look at like all podcasts and see who appeared on a particular podcast?
无论如何，如果你是一个听众，而且这可能会破坏我们试图扩大听众群体的初衷，如果你实际上只是为了这些 Sean Parent 的采访而来的，你将能够取消订阅 ADSP，而只订阅 Sean Parent 的个性频道。不管怎样，所以。所以我有疑问。这个个性频道功能是如何运作的？它是靠 AI 驱动的，还是你通过某种方式给嘉宾建立了索引？有没有什么办法可以像查看所有播客一样，看看谁出现在某个特定的播客中？
Is there like metadata for who's in the episode? Yeah, we can reserve this for another topic because I don't want to bore Sean and we have questions to ask him. So the short answer is, I wish it was that simple. It's very fuzzy. And in the midst of the mechanism that curates this is basically a Gemini. endpoint that once it has a short list of potential candidates, it feeds the title, the description, and says, is this actually an interview? Because in the world of podcast, there's a ton of people that, like, just put Elon Musk in the title in hopes that it shows up in, like, search results.
有没有关于谁在单集节目中的元数据？是的，我们可以把这个留到另一个话题再聊，因为我不想烦着 Sean，而且我们还有问题要问他。所以简短的回答是，我希望事情有那么简单。它是非常模糊的。而在策划这一机制的中间，基本上是一个 Gemini 端点，一旦它有了潜在候选人的短名单，它就会把标题和描述输入进去，并问道：“这真的是一次采访吗？”因为在播客的世界里，有大量的人，比如，只是在标题里加上 Elon Musk 的名字，希望它能出现在搜索结果中。
But they, they are not interviews with Elon Musk. And there is no, like, 100%, what do you call it, like zero false positives way other than getting like an AI to check. But we'll, we'll kick that down the road. Anyways, so maybe not by episode 300, but maybe by like 301, 302. If you want to go and unsubscribe from ADSP, if you're only here for Sean, you will be able to do that now. And with that, I mean, Sean, I guess a question, first question, did we miss any, is there like an interview with some Microsoft podcast from like 2008 that we don't know about that this missed? Or is this from what you can tell, a full curated list of all your interviews? I think there are some video interviews. That's probably all the podcast interviews. And there's some interviews in writing. So, but search my papers and presentations page. And you'll probably find them there.
但它们并不是对 Elon Musk 的采访。除了让 AI 来检查之外，没有百分之百的——你叫什么来着——零误报的方法。但我们会把这个话题往后放放。无论如何，所以也许不是在第 300 期，但可能在第 301 或 302 期左右。如果你想取消订阅 ADSP，如果你只是为了 Sean 而来，你现在就可以这么做了。借此机会，Sean，我想问个问题，第一个问题，我们有没有漏掉什么？比如说，有没有 2008 年微软某个播客的采访是我们不知道的，而这个工具漏掉了？或者据你所知，这是你所有采访的一个完整策划列表？我认为有一些视频采访。这可能涵盖了所有的播客采访。还有一些文字采访。所以，不过去搜搜我的论文和演讲页面，你可能会在那里找到它们。
That is some future turf that I'm sure YouTube would come after me is I saw a couple. One of the personalities I follow on here is Boris Churney, the creator of Claude Code. And I saw, if we can go to him, I saw that there was a couple interviews or like panel discussions on YouTube that I was like devastated. I was like, oh man, like how do I, but they weren't, they weren't in a podcast RSS feed, which means there's no way this is going to pick it up. But that would be amazing if it could go and like find articles published by someone or like YouTube panels and then like text to speech the articles. Although like now you're getting in like, I don't know, copyright infringement territory. And that's why YouTube would be upset. But it's an idea for exploration. Anyways, we will leave. a link to a future availability of this app, but also to the link that Sean just mentioned.
那将是我以后可能会涉足的领域，我确信 YouTube 会来找我麻烦，因为我看到了几个。我在这里关注的个性频道之一是 Claude Code 的创造者 Boris Churney。我看到，如果我们能找到他，我看到 YouTube 上有几个采访或小组讨论，当时我整个人都惊呆了。我想，天哪，我该怎么——但它们并不在播客的 RSS 订阅源中，这意味着这个工具绝对抓取不到它们。但如果它能去寻找某人发表的文章或 YouTube 小组讨论，然后将这些文章文字转语音，那将是 AMAZING（太棒了）。尽管现在你可能会进入，我不知道，侵犯版权的领域。这也是 YouTube 会不高兴的原因。但这是一个值得探索的想法。无论如何，我们会留下一个指向该应用未来可用性的链接，也会留下 Sean 刚刚提到的链接。
If you want to go check out any of his podcasts or articles or interviews on YouTube or past talks as well, we will leave links in the description. How has it been, Sean? I don't think it's been as long as the last time we talked to you in between. It's still been a couple months, a few months. So how has it been? It's been pretty good. Let's see what's gone on since then.
如果你想去查看他的任何播客、文章、YouTube 采访或过去的演讲，我们会在描述栏中留下链接。最近怎么样，Sean？我觉得距离我们上次和你交流并没有那么久。不过也确实过了好几个月了。所以最近过得怎么样？挺不错的。来看看这期间都发生了什么。
I took a sabbatical, so that was nice. kind of got out of here for seven weeks. So didn't think about work for a while. Although just before I left on sabbatical, I had installed Claude Code and started to kick the tires. Now I'm back and finding that I'm not writing code anymore, which is a bit of an existential crisis for me. So wait, what were you using before?
我休了个学术假，这感觉挺好的。差不多离开这里七周时间。所以有一段时间没去想工作的事了。虽然就在我休假前不久，我安装了 Claude Code 并开始试用了它。现在我回来了，发现自己不再写代码了，这对我来说有点像是一场生存危机。等等，那你之前用的是什么？
Because I know that we talked to you about how you had like resurrected some docs that you would always want it to do, but, you know, it was just you're not going to waste, cycles on that because it just wasn't saying for your buck, but then with AI, it accelerated. So what were you using back then? And I guess that is what you're using now. Yeah, so I was using cursor. And so it was largely at the stage of, you know, you write a prompt and, you know, it does the thing. And, you know, and had mixed results with it. So I had some good successes, like you mentioned resurrecting old docs and some things that were fairly
因为我知道我们跟你聊过，你曾把一些一直想做的文档给“复活”了，但是，你知道的，你不会在那上面浪费精力，因为性价比不高，但有了 AI 之后，速度就加快了。所以你当时用的是什么？我猜这也是你现在在用的东西。是的，所以我当时用的是 Cursor。所以它很大程度上处于这样一种阶段：你写下一个提示词，然后它就完成那件事，你知道的。而且，你对它的结果也是毁誉参半。所以我取得了一些不错的成功，比如你提到的复原旧文档，以及一些相当结构化的事情。
structured. But it wasn't nearly at the point where I am now where it's like I've got a whole workflow set up with cloud code, multi-agent workflow, and I give it a task, and it writes the spec, writes the plan, writes the code, does the code review, gets in an argument with a GitHub co-pilot about the code review, completes the code review, submits the PR, and moves on. So, yeah, it's my workflow at this point is largely it, automated. and I was thinking about, I've got about 34 open issues right now on my project. So I was thinking about, do I just, since I have the complete workflow for each thing, but right now I'm just manually kicking off each task,
但它远没有达到我现在的状态——我用 Claude Code 设置好了整套工作流，多智能体工作流。我给它一个任务，它编写规范、编写计划、编写代码、进行代码审查，甚至会为了代码审查的内容和 GitHub Copilot 吵一架，完成代码审查，提交 PR，然后继续下一个任务。所以，是的，我目前的工作流很大程度上就是这样，自动化的。我当时在想，我的项目现在大概有 34 个处于打开状态的 Issue。所以我在想，我是不是应该——既然我已经为每项任务都准备好了完整的工作流，但目前我只是手动触发每个任务——
am I at the point where I have enough confidence that I can tell, uh, tell Claude, hey, so you're not stepping on yourself, bucket this into about three work trees at a time, uh, where each of the work trees is working in a separate area. You know, implement the issue, see it all the way through. to push it to the code, pick up more issues, and just grind through all the remaining issues on the project. So this is fascinating because literally episode 299, I think I ended up calling, do we need humans in the loop? And Bryce and I, I was driving, which I shouldn't have been doing, but, you know, I had got behind schedule.
我已经有足够的信心去告诉 Claude：嘿，为了避免你自相矛盾，把这些任务一次分到大约三个工作树（work tree）里，每个工作树在不同的区域工作？实现这个 Issue，一直推进到底，将其推送到代码库，处理更多 Issue，然后一路攻克项目中所有剩余的 Issue。所以这非常迷人，因为就在第 299 期节目中，我好像把标题定为“我们还需要人在回路中吗？”我和 Bryce——当时我在开车，我本来不应该开的，但是，你知道的，我的进度落后了。
And we were having basically an argument. Bryce was saying, you know, for CCCL, it wasn't possible to like, I think, I think actually it was a 10x more issues or PR. issues you were saying it was like 300 open you're saying 34 and also too should we mention what what's the project i'm assuming it's one of the stu lab you know there's adam there's eve there's a bunch of things which is the one that you're working on right now yeah so on github right now it's it's it's github slash stu lab slash cell dash r s r s because it's written in rust and it sells c l which stands for common expression language. And I started on this project. The Adam and Eve projects have underlying them a common expression language in C++. And I'd started on this as kind of
我们基本上在争论。Bryz 说，对于 CCCL 来说，不可能去处理——我想，实际上那是多出 10 倍的 Issue 或 PR。你当时说有 300 个未关闭的，你说的是 34 个。还有，我们是不是应该提一下这是什么项目？我猜它是 Stu Lab 的其中之一，你知道的，有 Adam，有 Eve，有一堆东西，你现在正在做的是哪一个？是的，所以目前在 GitHub 上，它是 github 顺斜杠 stu-lab 顺斜杠 cell-rs，rs 是因为它是用 Rust 写的，cell 代表 Common Expression Language（通用表达式语言）。我开始这个项目时，
rewriting that infrastructure, but making it statically typed and writing it in Rust. And doing that. And I was doing that with cursor and making general progress. Now it's evolved into a re-implementation of property models, aka Adam, sitting on top of the cell infrastructure. And I've got a demo slash debugging application for looking at property models. I've got a language extension for for BS code that does you know formatting and syntax highlighting. There's a language server. So it does real-time diagnostics to your typing. A new planner for the probably haven't talked too much about Adam here, but it's a multi-way constraint system. And so there's a new planner for that, which was solved a long-standing problem with the atom system,
Adam 和 Eve 项目底层都有一个 C++ 的通用表达式语言。我开始做这个项目是为了重构那个基础设施，但让它具有静态类型，并用 Rust 编写。我就这么做了。我当时是用 Cursor 在做，并取得了总体进展。现在它已经演变成了一个坐在 cell 基础设施之上的属性模型（Property Models，又名 Adam）的重新实现。我有一个用于查看属性模型的演示/调试应用程序。我有一个针对 VS Code 的语言扩展，可以进行格式化和语法高亮。还有一个语言服务器。所以它能在你打字时进行实时诊断。还有一个针对概率模型的——我们可能在这里没有过多讨论 Adam，但它是一个多路约束系统。因此，这里有一个针对该系统的新规划器（planner），它解决了 Adam 系统长期存在的问题。
where the solution before was to manually hint it, but you had to know a lot to manually hint a particular class of problems to avoid a contradiction and had actually stubbed my toe trying to solve the planner on that with Alex Steppenoff, and then we invited in Bob Tarjan, who's a train award winner, because Alex had a correct observation that this somehow intersected, connected component problems,
以前的解决方案是手动给出提示（hint），但你必须了解很多关于如何手动提示特定问题类别的知识，以避免矛盾。我和亚历克斯·斯特潘诺夫（Alex Stepanov）一起尝试解决这个规划器问题时还碰过壁，后来我们邀请了图灵奖得主鲍勃·塔扬（Bob Tarjan），因为亚历克斯有一个正确的观察，即这不知何故与连通分量问题交织在一起，
and get graph theory and targent wrote the algorithm for that. And we couldn't come up with a solution to the planner. So I had this kind of hacky, hacky manual hinting that you had to do for the planner. And plot solved that. Wait, wait, wait. Hold up, hold up. You just said that between yourself, Alex Stepanov, who arguably should have won a Turing Award, and then another Turing Award winner who, did he win the Turing Award for Graph, like theory? For graph theory.
以及图论，而塔扬为此编写了算法。但我们当时想不出规划器的解决方案。所以我不得不为规划器使用那种有点 hack 的、临时的手动提示。而 Claude 解决了这个问题。等等，等等，等等。等一下。你刚才说，在你、亚历克斯·斯特潘诺夫（可以说是本该赢得图灵奖的人）以及另一位因——他是因图论赢得图灵奖的吗？因图论。
For, yeah, yeah. So you've got, you know, basically one and a half Turing Awards, three individuals couldn't solve it, and Claude code. What model were you using? Fable, Opus 4.8 or? No, it's actually, what is it, 4.6, I think, is all that Adobe's running at this point. Wow.
因为，是的，是的。所以你有（差不多）一个半图灵奖得主、三个人都无法解决的问题，而 Claude code 解决了。你用的是什么模型？Fable、Opus 4.8 还是？不，实际上是——是什么来着？4.6 吧，我想这就是 Adobe 目前运行的版本。哇。
Wow. And it was interesting because I, you know, the prompt I gave it was to go, I said, you know, this seems like it should be a solved problem somewhere. And so it was like, review the literature and see if you can find a solution. And if you can't see if you can build off some existing solutions because there's lots of planners for constraint systems out there. And so I thought, you know, maybe I've missed something and maybe it's a known problem. And I just just haven't found the answer.
哇。有趣的是，我——你知道的，我给它的提示是去，我说，你知道的，这在某处应该是一个已经解决的问题。所以它就像是：查阅文献，看看能不能找到解决方案。如果找不到，看看能否基于某些现有的解决方案进行构建，因为市面上有那么多针对约束系统的规划器。所以我想，你知道的，也许我漏掉了什么，也许这是一个已知问题，而我只是还没找到答案。
And so it went off and came back and said, well, it's not a known problem, but we can assemble some known algorithms and solve it. and including Targent's connected components fell in there. So the intuition was kind of right. And I have it set up, so it does its work in a work tree. So it did the work tree to solve the problem. And it was like, there, I'm done. And it pointed out while it was doing it, it said, oh, by the way, there's these three issues I spotted in your existing planner.
于是它去查了查，然后回来告诉我：嗯，这不是一个已知问题，但我们可以把一些已知的算法组合起来解决它。其中还包括塔扬的连通分量算法也被包含进去了。所以直觉是有点对的。我把它设置成在工作树（work tree）中进行工作。所以它创建了工作树来解决这个问题。然后它就像是：好了，我完成了。而在它完成的过程中，它指出，哦，顺便说一句，我在你现有的规划器里发现了这三个问题。
And so it came back and says it's done. And so I kick up my demo app and I write some test cases and kick the tires. And it's horribly wrong. It's horribly broken. And it was broken in the same way that we hit problems with previous attempts. And so I thought, well, that's very depressing. Okay, abandon that work tree and effort. And I'll go fix these three issues in the existing planner.
所以它回来后说完成了。然后我启动了我的演示应用，写了一些测试用例并试用了一下。结果错得离谱。它彻底坏掉了。而且它坏掉的方式和我们以前尝试时遇到的问题一模一样。所以我想，嗯，这太令人沮丧了。好吧，放弃那个工作树和努力吧。我要去修复现有规划器里的这三个问题。
And doing that, I found another issue and fixed that issue. And then I went back to Claw. and said, okay, so we've got this failed attempt in this work tree to solve this problem. So let's implement the hinting system that I've already built, which we know is a viable solution. And do you have any suggestions to clean that up? And Claude literally came back and said, well, why would you want to build a partial fix for this when we have the complete fix in this other work tree? And so it was like, well, it's not a complete fix.
在做这件事的过程中，我发现了另一个问题并修复了它。然后我回到 Claude 面前，说：好吧，我们在那个工作树里有一次失败的尝试来解决这个问题。所以让我们来实现我之前已经构建好的提示系统，我们知道这是一个可行的解决方案。你对清理它有什么建议吗？而 Claude  literalmente（字面意思上）回答说：嗯，既然我们在另一个工作树里有了完整的修复方案，你为什么还要为这个构建一个局部的修复方案呢？所以当时的情况就是：嗯，这不是一个完整的修复方案。
Here's a test that fails. And they came back and said, yeah, but at the time that I wrote this, the code. I didn't have these four additional pieces of information from your incorrect planner. Knowing that, I can fix it. Do you want me to? And it did. So it's been, I don't know, two and a half, almost three weeks now since it completed that. And I have not found an issue with it. So, so. Maybe it's just me that, you know, I, of course, find the AI to be very intelligent, but maybe it's just me that constantly has issues with it. Cheating. misbehaving, doing weird stuff.
这里有一个测试不通过。然后它回复说：是的，但我写这段代码的时候，我没有你那个不正确的规划器提供的这另外四条信息。知道了这些，我能修复它。你想让我这么做吗？然后它就照做了。所以，自从它完成那个任务以来，已经有，我不知道，两周半、快三周了。我还没有发现它有什么问题。所以，所以。也许只有我一个人——你知道的，我当然觉得 AI 非常聪明，但也许只有我一个人不断地遇到它作弊、出问题、做一些奇怪事情的麻烦？
It's, you know, I have the saying, LLM is people. And if you know, though, it's a reference to Soylent Green, you know, if you ever read the book or saw the movie. So I think I must have read the book in school. Right. So the short premise of Soilent Green for the listeners who may not know is that the planet is dying. And the only food source left for mankind is algae,
你知道的，我有一句名言：“LLM 就是人（LLM is people）”。如果你知道的话，这其实是对电影《超世纪绿晶体》（Soylent Green）的一个梗，你知道的，如果你读过这本书或看过这部电影的话。我想我上学时一定读过这本书。没错。所以对于可能不知道的听众来说，Soylent Green 的简要前提是地球正在消亡。人类留下的唯一食物来源是藻类，
the oceans. And so the government is harvesting algae from the oceans and creating a product called Soylent Green that they're using to feed the people. And the protagonist in the book discovers that this is a vast conspiracy, that the oceans are actually dead also, and that Soilent Green is made from corpses. And so the population will continue to diminution in mankind is doomed. So a happy upbeat story. So what do I mean when I say LLN? This people, Well, a few things. One, it's distilled from human knowledge on the internet, right? It's this, you know, grind up people knowledge, pour it into a system, and out at the end, you get some results. And it's, it's, you would expect things to, to reach some norm, some kind of average of intelligence in, in, in, in such a system.
海洋里的藻类。所以政府从海洋中收获藻类，制造出一种名为 Soylent Green 的产品来喂养人民。而书中的主角发现这是一个巨大的阴谋，海洋实际上也已经死了，Soylent Green 是用尸体制造的。因此，人类的数量将继续减少，人类命运已定。所以，这是一个快乐乐观的故事。那么当我说法 LLN（LLM）就是人时，我是什么意思呢？嗯，有几点。第一，它是从互联网上的人类知识中提炼出来的，对吧？这就是，你知道的，把人类的知识粉碎，注入一个系统，然后最终在末端得到一些结果。而且，你会期望事情达到某种规范，在这样的系统中达到某种智能的平均水平。
So, so it seems to, I think, exceed average because it's got a huge amount of knowledge, but it's not particularly bright. it just knows a lot of stuff. It's got a big brain and not a lot of wisdom. And so using the LLMs is a lot like a management task, right? What would you do if you were building a team of junior engineers? Well, you wouldn't say, I'm going to tell you what to go do, and you're going to run off and you're going to write a whole bunch of code, and you're going to come back in a day.
所以，所以它似乎，我认为它超越了平均水平，因为它拥有海量的知识，但它并不是特别聪明。它只是知道很多事情。它有一个很大的大脑，却没有多少大智慧。因此，使用 LLM 非常像是一项管理任务，对吧？如果你在组建一个初级工程师团队，你会怎么做？嗯，你不会说：我要告诉你去做什么，然后你们就会跑去写一堆代码，过几天再回来。
And I'm going to feel like my only choice is to accept that or dismiss it. and if I tell you how to fix it, you're going to go off and make the same mistakes again because you don't know that much and you're not that bright. That's not the way you're going to run a team, right? You're just going to frustrate yourself if you're managing a team like that. Instead, what you're going to do is you're going to start to build in process. You're going to say, look, for everything you write,
然后我觉得我唯一的选择要么是接受，要么是拒绝。如果我告诉你怎么修复它，你还是会去犯同样的错误，因为你懂得没那么多，你也没那么聪明。这不是你运营团队的方式，对吧？如果你那样管理团队，你只会让自己抓狂。相反，你要做的是开始建立流程。你会说：听着，对于你写的每一行代码，
I want you to write a contract on every component. I want you to write a set of unit tests that are only looking at the contract and the interfaces. I want the person next to you to then review all of that to make sure that it's correct. And then I want all those tests to run until they're passing. And you're going to build up a process, right? And you're going to start to say, okay, well, you know, you're kind of going off in the weeds here. So let's start by writing a spec and let's discuss what a good spec looks like and build out that process.
我要求你为每个组件编写一个契约（contract）。我要求你编写一组仅针对契约和接口的单元测试。我要求你旁边的人随后对所有这些进行审查，以确保它是正确的。然后我要求运行所有这些测试直到它们全部通过。你要建立一个流程，对吧？你会开始说：好吧，你知道的，你在这里有点跑偏了。所以让我们从编写一个规范开始，让我们讨论一下什么是好的规范，并建立这个流程。
And, you know, Claude Code, that's kind of the magic of Claude Code, right? It's got a lot of process built into it, and it's got a system with skills where you can augment existing skills and you can expand on the process. I have a lot of issues with Cloud Code that I would like to see addressed, but it's a good kind of 1.0 release of how do you build an engineering workflow? And just like, you know, if you're trying to build a product with a team, you're going to start to run into limitations. You're going to start to run into scaling issues. You're going to start to see, oh, look, if I'm making this thing too complex and I have to reason about a very large system and understandable, if I change something over here, it's going to permute something over
而且，你知道的，Claude Code，这正是 Claude Code 的魅力所在，对吧？它内置了许多流程，它有一个带有技能（skills）的系统，你可以在其中扩充现有技能并扩展流程。我对 Claude Code 有很多希望得到解决的问题，但它对于“如何构建工程工作流”来说，是一个相当不错的 1.0 版本发布。就像——你知道的，如果你试图和一个团队一起构建一个产品，你就会开始遇到局限性。你会开始遇到扩展性问题。你会开始看到，哦，看，如果我把这东西搞得太复杂，我必须对一个非常庞大的系统进行推理并使其易于理解——如果我在这里改变了什么，它就会在那个地方引起排列组合的变化，你就会开始打破系统内部的局部推理能力。所以，你知道的，构建一个可扩展 AI 系统的秘诀，其实就是构建一个可扩展团队的秘诀，对吧？你希望确保在你的代码库中保留局部推理能力，以便你可以让代码对孤立的部分进行推理，同时仍然能够将它们作为一个整体组装起来。你希望建立多层抽象，当它在处理系统的下一层时，它不必了解底层实现的全部细节——这就是为什么你希望在所有的函数上都有契约，并且基本上在进行的同时记录你的整个系统。
there and you start to break local reasoning within your system. So kind of, you know, the secret to building a scalable AI system is the secret to building a scalable team, right? You want to make sure that you preserve local reasoning within your code base so that you can have the code reason about things in isolated pieces and still be able to assemble them as a whole. And you want to build up layers of abstractions that when it's working on the next layer of your system, it doesn't have to know all about the implementation of everything under the hood, which is why you want contracts on all of your functions and all of, and basically you're documenting your whole system as you go.
而且文档不一定是给人看的。它是为了让 AI 不必对那些代码进行推理，它只需要查看契约，你知道的，然后构建你的系统。而且，你知道的，像 Rust 这样的受约束语言，我认为在这个领域很有价值，因为它们有助于引导系统走向正确性，在编译级别强制进行局部推理，并将其构建起来。所以到目前为止，我得到了相当不错的结果。即使在我这个绿色田野项目（新项目）中，你知道的，我也开始遇到扩展性问题了。你知道的，我注意到我大约有八九个组件，
And the documentation isn't necessarily for people. It's so that the AI doesn't have to reason about that. code, it can just look at the contracts, you know, and build your system up. And, you know, constrain languages like Rust, I think have a lot of value in this space as far as helping to guide the system to be correct and enforcing local reasoning at a compilation level and, you know, building it up. So so far I'm getting pretty good results. I am even on my little green field project here, you know, starting to run into scaling issues. You know, I'm noticing I've got about eight or nine components,
偶尔我必须做一个跨越所有组件的工作，而在这类任务上，它的表现是最差的。那仍然是在 Opus 4.6 上吗？仍然在 Opus 4.6 上，是的。我强烈建议说服 Adobe 让你升级到 4.8，因为……
and occasionally I've got to do a piece of work that spans all of the components, and on those pieces it does the worst job. Is that still on Opus 4.6? Still on Opus 4.6, yeah. I would highly encourage convincing Adobe to let you jump to 4.8 because...
或者你可以直接用 GPT-5.6。这取决于你能接触到什么。但我记得在某个时候，我在听的不同播客上听到过一些唱反调的人，他们说，哦，边际改进在递减。我的意思是，这取决于你的任务，但这些最新版本——比如从 4.6 到 4.7 再到 4.8 的渐进式升级，虽然我主要一直在用 Codex 模型——带来的最好的一点是，你所遇到的那些问题都消失了，不一定是代码生成本身或者它的能力发生了变化，而是那些你遇到过的情况，比如你要求它做 X，而你明知这是它不擅长的少数事情之一，或者你必须手把手教它。那些情况越来越频繁地消失了。我喜欢我认为它做不到的边界，它们只是稍微扩大了一点。而且它仍然，你知道的，就像我说的，反正它生成的代码。所以我不确定具体对你的情况是不是这样。是的，我怀疑这是真的。我的意思是，我甚至注意到——如果你看的话，Claude Code 几乎每天都在自我更新。
Or just you can use GPD 5.6. It depends on what you have access to. But I remember at some point, There's kind of these naysayers that I hear on different podcasts that I listen to, and they say, oh, like the marginal improvement is decreasing. And I mean, it depends on your task, but one of the best things that these latest, like, incremental from 4.6 to 4.7 to 4.8, although mostly I've been on Codex models, is that the issues that you have disappear, not necessarily the code gen or anything or what it's
它们是相对较小的改动，但它们累积得相当快，对吧？随着——你知道的，构建你自己的技能，就像：是的，我看到这里只有坚实的发展和改进。就像我说的，就在过去几天里我在想，好吧，我在我的项目中确实不怎么在回路中了，对吧？我几乎已经把我自己从这个过程中自动化出去了。所以，就像：我有足够的信心吗？也许我会起一个分支（fork），然后就这样：嘿，去吧，去完成它。就像，我想我有未关闭的 Issue 可以让我这个项目达到 1.0 的发布版本。
capable of changes, but like the things that you run into where, like, you, you, you ask it to do X and you just know that it's one of the few things it's not great at or you have to hold its hand. Those things like more and more just disappear. And I like the the boundaries of what I think it can't do, like they just grow a little bit. And it's still, you know, like I said, the code that it's generating anyway. So I'm not sure specifically for your case, but. Yeah, I suspect that that is true. I mean, I even notice, you know, if you look, Claude Code updates itself practically daily.
所以大概就是：是的，把那些全部刷完，然后把这个收尾。有没有什么方法能让你确信它确实完成了？比如，这取决于你测试四样目前（无论是 Adam 还是 cell-rs）都做不到的事情？如果你去测试那个，你就知道在这之前的一切有 98% 或 99% 的几率都在工作，还是说这需要花点时间？不，到目前为止，核心规划器我已经完成了。
and they're relatively minor changes, but they accumulate fairly rapidly, right? And that with, you know, building out your own skills, it's like, yeah, I see there's just this solid progression of improvement. And like I said, just the last couple days I've been thinking, well, I'm really not in the loop much in my project anymore, right? I've almost automated my way out of it. And so, like, do I have enough confidence? You know, maybe I'll spin up a fork and just be like, hey, go, go complete it. Just like, I think I have issues open to get me to 1.0 for a release on this.
所以这可以说是约束系统的核心。剩下的就是外围的功能了，对吧？所以，只需要一套良好的单元测试（我实际上让它自动编写了这些测试），我认为就足够了。而且我已经有了足够多的测试用例和类似的东西在里面，它们已经预先写好了桩函数（stubbed），比如：好的，在我开启这个功能之前，我不能点亮这个功能，对吧？你知道的，到了这一步，我想即使我自己按照遵循的流程来做，可能也还需要一两个月的时间；但如果我彻底放手不管它，我不知道，也许三四天吧。我有过几次这样的经历：如果我把所有 Issue 都交由它自由发挥，
So it would be like, yeah, just grind through all of those and wrap this up. Is there a way that you would be confident that it actually did it? Like, is it a matter of you testing like four things that currently, you know, whether it's Adam or cell RS aren't capable of and that if you just like, it's like, you know, the stable sort is at the top of, you know, a bunch of other things. If you just go test that, you know that everything leading up to it like 98% chance or 99% chances working or would it take some time? No, at this point, I've got the core planner done.
对于我的许多项目来说，它并不能在第一次尝试时就把它做好，这可能只是因为我的 Issue 规范得不够充分，或者没有进行充分的测试。但是，是的，我认为问题在于，在很多情况下，我没有充分规范问题，所以我不能只是把所有 Issue 都扔给它不管，因为它会把事情搞得一团糟。
And so that's kind of the core of the constraint system. And so the rest of it is features on the peripheral, right? right and so just you know a good set of unit tests which actually automated the writing of those i think cover it and i've got enough test cases and stuff in there that are already stubbed with like okay i can't can't light this up until i turn this feature on right you know at this point i think even if i were to do it with the process i'm following i'm probably maybe a month or two away but if i just let it loose i don't know maybe three four days i have experienced on a few times if I just let it loose on all the issues,
是的，我的意思是，一个非常诚实的发现是，大多数时候，嗯，你知道的，所以我把这些规则内置到了我的要求中，因为很多时候它会对某个更大的任务进行多阶段的实现。而在这样做的时候，也许我在它完成所有任务之前就把它停下来了，因为我想先做一些其他事情。对于它没有完成的剩余阶段，我会开着一个打开的 GitHub Issue。如果它在工作时发现一些超出范围但它认为应该修复的事情，我会让 Claude 为这些事情打开 GitHub Issue。如果我发现了什么，我通常会要求
that for a lot of my projects, it doesn't get it right in the first try, and that might just be that my issues are not well-specified enough or there aren't sufficient testing. But, yeah, I think that the problem, in a lot of cases, I've not sufficiently specified the problem, and so I can't just let it loose on all the issues because it just make a mess of things.
Claude 用一个简短的提示词帮我打开一个 GitHub Issue，通常这发生在正在做某事的过程中，所以它理解周围的上下文，我会写一个一行的提示词，然后它就会打开一个三页纸的 Issue，并说：你知道的，而且写得相当好。
Yeah, I mean, a very honest. thing that I found is most of the time, well, you know, so I built into my rules that I say, because a lot of times it will do like a multi-phase implementation of some larger task. And in doing that, maybe I stop it before it completes all the tasks because I want to do some other things first. I will have an open GitHub issues for the remaining phases it didn't do. If it finds things while it's working that are out of scope, but it thinks should be fixed, I have Claude open GitHub issues for those. If I spot something, I will typically ask
它会是：我发现了这个问题，这就是它在代码中的位置，这就是为什么它是一个问题，并对此进行全面的解释，仅仅因为我指出了它。所以我的 GitHub Issue 往往非常冗长和详细，但我甚至都没有亲自写它们。是的，这太神奇了。
Claude to open my GitHub issue with a small prompt, and usually that's in the middle of working on something, so it understands the context around it, and I'll write a one-line prompt, and it will open a three-page issue and be like, you know, and quite well written.
我很想听听你是如何做到——或者你是否仅靠智能体（agents）就能做到这一点的，因为也许我只是哪里做错了。我的意思是，有几件事。比如，你知道的，所以我正在从事一个绿色田野项目（全新项目）。这是一个相对较小、狭窄的项目，在这个主题上有 20 年的学术论文，其中几篇还是我写的。所以这是一个定义相对明确且相对狭窄、具体的问题。现在，你知道的，我脑海深处的声音之一是，
It'll be, you know, I identify this problem, and here's where it is in the code, and this is why it's a problem, and do a full explanation on it, just because I pointed it out. So my GitHub issues tend to be, you know, very verbose and detailed, but I'm not even writing those. Yeah, that's fascinating.
我最初对这个项目的设想是，你知道的，属性模型（property models）已经存在了 20 多年了。为什么它们没有被广泛使用？你知道的，如果它们在 Adobe 被广泛使用，它们将消除我们产品中 15% 到 30% 的代码。所以这看起来应该是一个巨大的胜利。但我发现它们对人们来说很难编写，而且人们很难在这种空间里思考。所以这需要一种不同的思维方式。因此，当我开始重新审视这一点时，我的前提是：如果我，你知道的，构建
I'll be interested to hear how, like, whether you're able to get there with just the agents, because maybe I'm just doing something wrong. I mean, there's a few things. Like, you know, so I'm working in a green field. a relatively small, narrow project that's got, you know, 20 years of academic papers written on the topic of which several I've written. So it's a relatively well-defined and relatively narrow, narrow problem. Now, you know, one voice in the back of my head that I have is,
一个更好的引擎，能够消除正在发生的一些手动提示。我提到了其中的一个实例。有两个实例需要手动提示。如果我能消除这两个实例，如果我通过将其改为静态类型而不是动态类型来收紧约束，并且我围绕它添加了更好的工具，你知道的，如果我在其上放一个语言服务器，然后将约束系统的图表可视化，那么也许人们就会理解它，并且会有一个显著的提升。
is my original premise on this, you know, it's kind of, you know, property models now have been around for 20-something years. Why aren't they in widespread use? You know, if they were in widespread use at Adobe, they would eliminate somewhere between 15% and 30% of the code in our products. So it seems like it would be a big win. But I've found that they are difficult for people to author, and it's a difficult space for people to think in. And so it takes kind of a different mindset. And so my premise when I started to revisit this was, well, if I, you know, build
但现在，感觉像是：我认为人们不会再编写这个了，因为我认为人们以后都不会写代码了。所以整个论点和前提都变了：这是一种描述问题的更高阶方式，它比描述这类问题的典型命令式代码要密集得多。因此，如果我们为此构建一个领域特定语言（DSL），AI 就能更高效地在该 DSL 内部进行编写，并取得更好的结果以及更低的 Token 成本？
a better engine that requires, you know, eliminate some of the manual hinting that's going on. I mentioned one instance of it. There were two instances where kind of manual hinting was required. If I could eliminate those two instances, if I tighten the constraints a little bit by making it statically typed instead of dynamically typed, and I added better tooling around it, you know, if I put a language server on it and then group in a, could visualize the graph for the constraint system, then maybe people would understand it and it would be a significant uptick.
所以我最近一直在做大量关于评估编程语言效率以及 DSL 与主流语言效率的工作。其中一个主要的结论是，存在非常大的既得利益偏见（incumbency bias）。所以，你知道的，如果你有一些新的 DSL 或某些新的框架之类的东西，即使它更好、更高效，它在 Token 效率上也可能不如那个存在了很久的古老、笨拙的现有东西，
But now, it's like, I don't think people will be authoring this, because I don't think people will be authoring code. So the whole thesis and premise changes to, this is a higher level way to describe a problem that is much denser than the typical imperative code for describing this type of problem. And so if we build a DSL for this, can the AI is more efficiently author inside of that DSL and have better outcomes and lower token cost?
仅仅是因为有关于它的文献更多。关于它的知识更多。模型是在它上面预训练的。模型是在它上面后训练的，等等。没错。
So I've been doing a lot of work recently on evaluating programming language efficiency and the efficiency of DSLs versus more mainstream languages. And one of the main takeaways is that there's a very large incumbency bias. So, you know, if you've got some new DSL or some new framework or something that even if it's better and more efficient, it might be less token efficient than the ancient, crafty existing thing that's been around. for a long time just because there's more literature on it. There's more knowledge on it. The model was pre-trained on it. The model was post-trained on it, et cetera. Yep.
这有点令人悲伤，也让人有点意外。我们有所有这些用于编写 CUDA 内核的很酷的 Python DSL。而 CUDA C++ 的表现却出奇地好。最有趣的是，CUDA C++ 的 JIT 编译时间实际上与许多 DSL 相当。但我对此有一个理论，我的理论是，这归因于他们编写的代码类型。所以智能体（agents）编写代码时，它们不使用模板。它们在编写 C++ 代码时不用抽象。
Which is a little sad, a little surprising. We have all these cool like Python DSLs for authoring Kuta kernels. And Kuta C++ did surprisingly well. The most interesting thing is that the JIT compilation times for Kuta C++ were actually comparable to a lot of the DSLs. But I have a theory about that, and my theory is that that's because of the type of code that they're writing. So the agents write, they don't use templates. They don't use abstraction when they're writing their C++ code.
它们只是像：我只为每件事物进行特化。我只为每件事物编写简单的函数。我要写 C 风格的代码，而且我要写很多很多。所以，是的，它编译起来很快，因为它没有任何让 C++ 编译变慢的东西，比如模板实例化。但代码量要大得多。你本以为在某个时候，代码会变得足够像面条代码（spaghetti code），从而更难处理。也许确实如此，而我们只是还没有把实验做到那个地步。
They're just like, I'll just specialize for everything. I'll just have simple functions for everything. I'm going to write C style code, and I'm just going to write a lot of it. And so, yeah, it's fast to compile because it doesn't have any of the things that make C++ slow to compile, like template instantiation. but there's just a lot more code. And you would think at some point that the code would get to be enough spaghetti code that would be harder for them to work with. And maybe it does, and we just haven't run the experiments out far enough.
他们就像是，我干脆为所有事情都进行专门设计。我为所有事情都写简单的函数。我要写 C 风格的代码，而且要写很多。所以，是的，它编译起来很快，因为它没有那些让 C++ 编译变慢的东西，比如模板实例化。但代码量大得多。你可能会想，在某个时候，代码会变成足够多的面条式代码，让他们很难处理。也许确实如此，只是我们的实验还没进行到那个阶段。
But, yeah, they're surprisingly good at writing awful C-style code. Yeah, I mean, this goes back to the LLN's people premise, right? Well, it's really interesting that you say that, because the other finding that I've had is that all of the things that we perceive as being difficult for humans to deal with. And all of the developer productivity concerns that we have about like diagnostics, stuff like that, it's all an issue for agents too. Like two of the biggest sources of token inefficiency, aside from reward hacking,
但，是的，它们在编写糟糕的C风格代码方面出奇地好。是的，我的意思是，这回到了LLM使用者的前提，对吧？嗯，你这么说真的很有趣，因为我得到的另一个发现是，所有我们认为人类难以应对的事情，以及我们对诸如诊断之类的开发者生产力问题的所有担忧，对Agent来说也都是问题。比如，除了奖励造假之外，导致Token效率低下的两个最大原因，
two of the biggest. Well, actually, including reward hacking for one of them, diagnostics is a big one. In particular, diagnostics that happen late. The later the diagnostic, the worse it is, If you only find out about the failure at runtime, then, like, you know, the model goes and, like, writes out a prototype of the code. It's like, oh, let me see if this compiles.
两个最大原因。嗯，事实上，其中一个包括奖励造假，诊断就是一个大问题。特别是那些发生得很晚的诊断。诊断发现得越晚，情况就越糟。如果你只在运行时才发现失败，那么，你知道的，模型就会去写出一段代码的原型。它会想，哦，让我看看这能不能编译。
Oh, it compiles. Okay, I'll flush it out a little bit more. And then it keeps going and keeps going. And then eventually it goes and runs it. And then only then does it learn that it wasted all that time because there was a mistake. Or, like, you know, it's something where it passes some of the tests. It passes some, like, lightweight tests, but then you run it with the full test suite. And, oh, no, that didn't work.
哦，编译通过了。好的，我再把它完善一点。然后它继续运行，继续运行。最后它去运行了这段代码。直到那时，它才知道自己浪费了所有时间，因为里面有个错误。或者，你知道的，某种通过了部分测试的情况。它通过了一些轻量级的测试，但当你用完整的测试套件运行它时，糟糕，这行不通。
It's like, okay, well, if those were all errors that we could have caught at compile time, it would have been easier. And ironically, the JIT compiled languages, the JIT compiled DSL languages that are often easier for, you know, higher level, maybe I should say, not necessarily easier, but they're higher level. You have more of those types of failures with that type of language than with a statically compiled language like C++. And presumably things like Rust would also be good. the other big source of token inefficiency, at least in our line of work, is race conditions and concurrency. And there's two factors to this. One, of course, just concurrent programming and debugging is hard. The bigger problem is that they're flaky. So the model goes in it, it writes the code that introduces the race condition, and it runs the tests, and they pass, and it's like, great.
这就好比，好吧，如果这些都是我们在编译时就能捕获的错误，那就会容易得多。具有讽刺的是，JIT编译语言，那些JIT编译的DSL语言，对于更高级别的任务来说通常更容易，也许我应该说，不一定更容易，但它们更高级。在使用这种语言时，你会遇到比使用像C++这样的静态编译语言更多的这类错误。据推测，像Rust这样的语言也会很好。Token效率低下的另一个主要原因，至少在我们这行里，是竞态条件和并发性。这有两个因素。第一，当然，并发编程和调试本身就很难。更大的问题是它们是不稳定的。所以模型进去写了引入竞态条件的代码，然后它运行测试，测试通过了，它就会觉得太棒了。
And then it keeps working. And maybe you've got like a parallel swarm of agents that are working. And then like, you know, some of them start having failures. And they're like, oh, that's weird. Where did this failure come from? And you could end up having it waste just as a human would, waste hours trying to track down this flaky, you know, race condition. And it's, there's something very rewarding, redeeming about seeing all of the things that people that we who have cared about developer productivity for years have said that these things matter. It's, it's very, it's nice to see those, like, reflected in. the actual token efficiency.
然后它继续工作。也许你有一个并行的Agent集群在工作。然后，你知道的，其中一些开始出现故障。它们就会想，哦，这真奇怪。这个故障是从哪来的？你最终可能会像人类一样，浪费几个小时来追踪这个不稳定的竞态条件。并且，看到那些我们这些多年来一直关心开发者生产力的人说过重要的事情，在实际的Token效率中得到反映，这有一种非常 rewarding（有意义）、弥补遗憾的感觉。
Vindicating is the word you're looking at. Vindicated. I feel very vindicated. Here, I'll show you, I'll show you one thing. I just happened to have this up. This was, this was not, not prepared. I'll show you this one thing, which was, this was, this is the auto research log for the, the cub histogram auto research run that ran for like six days,
Vindicating（得到证实）正是你想用的词。Vindicated（得到证实）。我感到非常有底气。来，我给你看，我给你看一样东西。我正好把这个打开了。这不是提前准备好的。我给你看这个，这是auto research的日志，关于那个跑了大约六天的cub histogram auto research运行，
130 hours. And all of these yellow lines are commits where it did some form of reward hacking or cheating that was found out retroactively. And all of the blue dotted lines are places where it found race conditions. So there's like an eight hour period. There's one eight hour period at 50 hours. And there's another couple hour period early on where it introduced some race condition and then just wasted enormous amounts of resources trying to get out of it in like realizing, oh, I made this mistake.
130个小时。所有这些黄线都是它进行某种奖励造假或作弊的commit，这些作弊后来被追溯发现了。所有这些蓝色的虚线都是它发现竞态条件的地方。所以有一个八小时的周期。在50小时的时候有一个八小时的周期。早期还有另一个几小时的周期，它引入了一些竞态条件，然后为了摆脱它，浪费了大量的资源，最后意识到，哦，我犯了这个错误。
oh, I need to go back and, you know, like roll back all of this work and then all the work that I did that built on top of it was maybe invalid. And it's just like a, it takes a lot of effort to recover. Yes. And yeah, well, you're somewhat, you know, making my point, which is, I think, just like people, right, right, there's this incumbent bias where it's like, oh, well, it's doing a good job with C++, but then, you know, you wouldn't be having race conditions if you were writing in Rust, for example.
哦，我需要回去，你知道的，比如回滚所有这些工作，然后我在此基础上构建的所有工作可能都是无效的。这就像，恢复它需要付出很大的努力。是的。是的，嗯，你某种程度上，你知道的，证明了我的观点，那就是，我认为就像人一样，对吧，对吧，这里存在一种现有的偏见，就像是，哦，好吧，它在C++上做得很好，但随后，你知道的，如果你用Rust编写，就不会出现竞态条件，例如。
Right, right. That's, yeah. That's one of the things that I certainly saw in some of my results, that in abstraction layers where you're not explicitly doing the concurrency, where it's sort of automated from you and these sort of higher level functional paradigms like tile programming, you, you know, you don't end up spending time on these errors because they just, they just don't come up. The other thing, the thing I've been thinking about today is how do we make models better at this and like how do we come up with like a benchmark suite for this and my idea is well let's let's come up with like a set of tasks where the model is given some code and the code has a race condition in it already but the model doesn't know that and we give it some other tasks to do in the code base where it's going to become hampered by this race condition and it'll have to go and find the race condition and fix it and you come up with like 10 tasks like that but the challenge is that, like, I was thinking, oh, we should call this racebench. But the thing is, if you call it race bench,
对，对。那是，是的。我在自己的一些结果中确实看到了这一点，在那些你不需要显式处理并发的抽象层中，它对你来说是某种程度上自动化的，以及诸如分块编程（tile programming）这样更高级别的函数式范式，你，你知道的，最终不会把时间花在这些错误上，因为它们根本，根本就不会出现。另一件事，我今天一直在想的事情是，我们如何让模型在这方面做得更好，以及我们如何为此想出一套基准测试套件（benchmark suite），我的想法是，让我们想出一组任务，模型会拿到一些代码，代码中已经包含了一个竞态条件，但模型并不知道这一点，我们在代码库中给它一些其他的任务要做，它会受到这个竞态条件的阻碍，它必须去找到这个竞态条件并修复它，你设计出大约10个这样的任务，但挑战在于，就像，我当时在想，哦，我们应该把这叫做racebench。但问题是，如果你把它叫做racebench，
then the model's going to see in the name of the thing that it's called racebench. And it's going to be like, oh, I know what's going on here. Yeah. Yeah, instead of benchmarking, I mean, where I would like to get to is get, you know, an engineering process app that I can package up a complete engineering workflow into and deploy it at scale on team. And then I can change that workflow and permute it, right? Right.
那么模型在看到这个东西的名字叫racebench时就会注意到。它就会想，哦，我知道这里是怎么回事了。对。是的，与其做基准测试，我的意思是，我希望达到的目标是，获得一个工程流程App，我可以将一个完整的工程工作流打包到其中，并在团队中大规模部署它。然后我可以改变这个工作流并对它进行置换，对吧？对。
I can be like, like, you know, dial up and down the detailing contracts or, or change the rules for how unit tests are written or change the rules around specification and deploy this at scale enough so that I can be measuring teams and saying, okay, you know, how much code is this team generating and how much of the code is coming out of their product? And now I can start to do testing where I can say, okay, I'm going to deploy this on various teams and see, does their productivity go up or down, right? Are they getting better results at lower cost or not? And, you know, it's the same thing as doing like, you know, a medication study. Right.
我可以像，你知道的，调高或调低详细契约（detailing contracts），或者更改单元测试编写的规则，或者更改围绕规范的规则，并将其大规模部署到足以让我能够衡量团队并说，好吧，你知道的，这个团队正在生成多少代码，其中有多少代码来自他们的产品？现在我可以开始进行测试，我可以宣称，好吧，我将把它部署在各个团队上，看看他们的生产力是上升还是下降，对吧？他们是否以更低的成本获得了更好的结果？而且，你知道的，这和做像药物研究是一样的。对。
I think tools around the software engineering process and in particular tools and frameworks for that help us test and ensure quality in figuring out how to quantify quality and measure code quality are going to, it's going to become a really important industry. That sounded like a compelling pitch for a Sean Parent startup. I would buy shares in that in that and that Sean Parent start. of. Yeah. Not, you know, I don't know, maybe Anthropics should hire me and I will help them build the product.
我认为围绕软件工程流程的工具，特别是那些帮助我们测试和确保质量、弄清楚如何量化质量以及衡量代码质量的工具和框架，将成为一个非常重要的行业。这听起来像是对Sean Parent初创公司的一个极具说服力的推销。我会买那家Sean Parent初创公司的股份。是的。不是，你知道的，我不知道，也许Anthropic应该雇佣我，我来帮他们打造这个产品。
I have the expertise in the engineering process side, but not in the, how do you build the LLM harness and do the training on that end. So if I were to do a startup, I would have to hire good people, which are hard to come by with that expertise. I've started getting more into that world on the training side of things recently. Yeah, it's very interesting process of like thinking like you end up thinking a lot about like how are you, how does the model learn and then like how are you going to teach it and like what thing, especially for post training. Like what, you know, just in the same way that you'd think about how you would teach to humans like, but just sort of more at a scale and industrialized. Like how would I actually distill these sometimes intangible things that I care about into something that I can. you know, make testable and then like trainable and like some loop where I can tell it, I can give it a task and I can have it go practice that task a lot of times. But it's tough because like you have
我在工程流程方面有专业知识，但在如何构建LLM端到端工具链（harness）并在那一端进行训练方面没有。所以如果我要创业，我必须雇佣优秀的人才，而具备这种专业知识的人很难找到。我最近开始更多地涉足训练那一侧的世界。是的，这是一个非常有趣的过程，比如你会思考很多关于你如何，模型是如何学习的，然后你将如何教它，以及什么东西，特别是对于后期训练。就像什么，你知道的，就像你思考如何教人类一样，但只是更具规模化和工业化。我该如何真正将这些我关心的有时无形的东西提炼成我可以，你知道的，使其可测试，然后可训练的东西，以及某种循环，我可以在其中给它一个任务，让它去练习那个任务很多次。但这很难，因为你必须
to think about all these things that maybe we've not verbalized or written down or formalized. And like, how do we do that? Yeah. Yeah. My approach on that so far has been, you know, just keeping an eye kind of spot checking and monitoring things. And when I find something that I find objectionable telling Claude, okay, you know, this is, I find this objectionable, this is why. Can you turn that into a skill or a rule? Let me review that. Now apply that across the entire code base, right? Catching all the things that I didn't catch.
考虑所有这些我们可能还没有用言语表达、写下来或规范化的事情。然后，我们该怎么做？对。是的。我到目前为止的方法是，你知道的，只是密切关注、抽查和监控事情。当我发现我认为不可接受的事情时，告诉Claude，好的，你知道的，我觉得这不可接受，原因如下。你能把它变成一个技能或规则吗？让我复审一下。现在把它应用到整个代码库中，对吧？捕获所有我没有捕获到的东西。
And now let me look at the diffs. And, you know, I might throw it away a couple times and be like, no, no, no, that's not what I meant, not what I said. Right? But review the dips and be like, okay, refine that a couple times until I'm happy with the result. I'm like, okay, now we can commit that PR, which is just an update to the rule set and move on to the next thing. It's funny that you say that to you because there's a theme across this discussion, which is like, you know, initially, although you made me think that it worked the first time. But when you had cloud code, you know, tackle the connected component, you know, plus plus problem, it failed at first.
现在让我看看diff（代码差异）。而且，你知道的，我可能会扔掉它几次，然后说，不，不，不，这不是我的意思，我不是这么说的。对吧？但是复审diff并说，好吧，完善几次，直到我对结果满意。我想，好吧，现在我们可以提交那个PR了，这只是对规则集的更新，然后继续下一件事。你这么说很有趣，因为这次讨论中有一个主题，那就是，最初，尽管你让我觉得它第一次就成功了。但是当你让Claude Code，你知道的，处理连通分量（connected component）加加问题时，它一开始失败了，
and then you said, okay, well, you didn't do that successfully, but then you came back to it, and then luckily it just said, oh, well, like, if you had given me this extra information, like I could have used that. And the same thing here, right? Like, you're asking it to go and create a quad skill and then, you know, applied across the codebase, and then you iterate. And I feel like a lot of folks, they expect this stuff to just work. Like, it's just like, you know, one shot or zero shot or whatever, you tell it, and then it's just perfect.
然后你说，好吧，你没有成功做到这一点，但后来你又回过头来，幸运的是它直接说，哦，好吧，如果你把这个额外的信息给我，你知道的，我就可以用它了。这里也是一样，对吧？就像，你要求它去创建一个Claude技能，然后，你知道的，把它应用到代码库中，然后你进行迭代。我感觉很多人，他们期望这些东西能直接起作用。就像，你知道的，只需要一次（one-shot）或零次（zero-shot）或者随便什么，你告诉它，然后它就完美了。
And, like, I find that so shocking because that is not how humanity, like, any points in time, whether it's engineering or mathematics or just working with any people, whether it's like a career or profession or you're just having a conversation about like, oh, you know, what should we do with the backyard? You know, it's not like you ask a question, there's an answer and then boom, that's it. We're done. It's like a back and forth. And I feel like a part of the reason that I am so successful with these models is that it's not that I've suspended disbelief. It's just that I know that like if I work well with these tools, like I can get where I want to go, way faster than I could, like before.
并且，我发现这太令人震惊了，因为这并不是人类的方式，在任何时间点，无论是工程学、数学，还是与任何人合作，无论是职业、专业，还是你只是在进行关于“哦，你知道的，我们该拿后院怎么办”的对话。这都不是说你问一个问题，然后就有一个答案，然后轰，就这样。我们完成了。这就像是一个来回的互动。我感觉我之所以能用好这些模型，部分原因并不是我暂停了怀疑。只是我知道，如果我能与这些工具很好地配合，你知道的，我能比以前更快地到达我想去的地方。
And it is not necessarily going to be perfect. But like whenever it fails, I don't think, like, why is this not working? I think to myself, yeah, I probably didn't communicate that as clearly as I could have. Like, you know, there's a quote from a movie, I think it's called The Last Emperor. And it's about like the Last Emperor of China, Poo-E, I believe.
它不一定完美。但每当它失败时，我不会想，为什么这不管用？我在心里想，是的，我可能没有像自己本可以做到的那样清晰地表达出来。就像，你知道的，电影里有一句台词，我想它叫《末代皇帝》。讲的是中国末代皇帝，溥仪，我相信是这样。
And there's this great quote and it says, a gentleman cannot mean what he says if he does not say what he means. Words are important. Why are words important? If you cannot say what you mean, your majesty, you will never mean what you say. And a gentleman should always mean what he says. Like, I always whip that out every once in a while when, like, you know, my shema and I, my wife, you know, she says something. She's like, oh, you know what I meant.
有一句很棒的台词，它是这样说的：如果一个人不说他所指的意思，他就不能指望他的话有意义。言辞很重要。为什么言辞很重要？如果你不能说出你所指的意思，陛下，你就永远不会言行一致。而一个绅士应该总是言行一致。就像，每当我和我的shema，我的妻子，你知道的，她说了一些话时，我总是偶尔会搬出这句。她说，哦，你知道我的意思的。
And I was like, no, I don't know what you meant. You know, you literally said something. And then expected me to not take the semantics of what you said, like, just, oh, wow, you know, why do you have to be so, like, hyperatological? And I'm like, I just listened to what you said. Anyways, we love each other. We're doing great. baby's on the way. But the point being is that, like, communication has become so important with these AIs. They do take what we say literally. And even sometimes it actually reads between
而我会说，不，我不知道你是什么意思。你知道的，你字面意思就是这么说的。然后还期望我不去理会你所说话语的语义，就像，哦，哇，你知道的，你为什么非要这么吹毛求疵呢？而我会说，我只是在听你说了什么。无论如何，我们相爱。我们过得很好。宝宝就要出生了。但重点是，与这些AI的沟通变得如此重要。它们确实会字面理解我们所说的话。甚至有时它们实际上还能看穿
the lines. It knows that what you meant is actually different than what you said, because, like you said, it's trained, you know, LLM is human. It's trained on so much text and books that is reading between the lines. And it's, well, you know, if the person said X, what they actually probably meant is that, you know, A, B, C, D, and then you get X. And so I'm going to assume that that's the case. and then you watch it thinking, you're like, holy F, like, that is crazy. Like, it knew what I meant, even though I didn't say what I should have. God, I'm just pitching you all on all of my ideas today. We're going to tell you to start a second startup?
字里行间。它知道你的意思其实和你说的不同，因为就像你说的，它经过训练，你知道的，LLM就是人类。它在如此多的文本和书本上接受过训练，以至于它能够看穿字里行间。而且它会想，嗯，如果这个人说了X，他们实际的意思可能就是，你知道的，A、B、C、D，然后你得到了X。所以我假设情况就是这样。然后你看着它思考，你会觉得，天哪，F，这太疯狂了。就像，它知道我的意思，即使我没有说出我应该说的话。天哪，我今天简直在向你们推销我所有的想法。我们要告诉你要开始第二次创业了吗？
Well, this is less a startup, but I was thinking about, like, how do I, how do I collect all of those things, all those, you know, design sensibilities? And like you could, I'm thinking both about how you can do this in like a synthetic way. How can I generate these design sensibilities from a model? But also, how can I collect it from humans? And that's what led me to the idea of Tinder for code. So it's like an app where you get shown some snippet of code. And you're not looking at it for very long.
嗯，这不太算创业，但我一直在想，如何，我该如何收集所有这些东西，所有那些，你知道的，设计感？你可以，我既在考虑你如何能以一种合成的方式做到这一点。我如何从模型中生成这些设计感？但同时，我如何从人类那里收集它？这让我萌生了“代码Tinder”的想法。所以它就像是一个App，你会看到一些代码片段。而且你看它的时间不会很长。
And you're deciding, like, is it a good code or bad code? And then if you decide it's like either way, like you leave some feedback, maybe it's not even text. Maybe like, you know, there's some. list of options. But the idea is like it's going to show you like, you know, 10 lines or like one function. And it's going to be like, is this good or bad?
然后你在决定，这是好代码还是坏代码？然后如果你决定了，不管是哪种，你都会留下一些反馈，也许甚至都不是文字。也许，你知道的，有一些选项列表。但想法是它会向你展示，你知道的，10行或者一个函数。然后它会问，这是好的还是坏的？
And I don't know. Just it's like they came up with it as I was working out my mother earlier. And I'm like, hmm, maybe this could get me the data I need. And there was some leaderboard, but I don't know what to call it yet. I'm sure you two could give me a good name for what we would call. Just steal, Zuckerberg, it's hot or not, except it's for codes. Yeah. I've been wanting to ask since you said at the beginning of the podcast, Sean,
我不知道。只是，这就像我之前在锻炼时想出来的。然后我在想，嗯，这也许能帮我获得我需要的数据。还有一个排行榜，但我还不知道该叫它什么。你们俩肯定能为我们称呼它的名字起个好名字。直接偷扎克伯格的创意，就是Hot or Not（看脸评分），只不过这是针对代码的。是的。自从你在播客开始时说过，Sean，
that you are going through like a little existential crisis because, you know, join the club. And then you also said, I don't know, 30 minutes later, that you don't think people are going to be authoring code. And anyway, I'm just, I want to get your, your larger thoughts on, yeah, like those two statements. Expound. I want to know more because like I spend a ton of my time talking to my wife about like, this is going great. I'm very excited, but like, let's play this out. And like, I am sure I will be employed if I want to be employed, you know, several years from now. But I definitely do not think what I am, you know, what my job looks like today. I think it's going to be vastly different. And I'm in a great position. But like I just, you know, we have these philosophical discussions where I'm just like, what is actually society even. I tried to have this discussion with Bryce last time. But he missed what I was trying to say. And it's just like, you know, what is the point? You know, like it hasn't come.
你正在经历一点小小的生存危机，因为，你知道的，欢迎加入俱乐部。然后你还在大概30分钟后说过，你不认为人们以后还会编写代码。无论如何，我只是，我想听听你对，关于这两句话的更大想法。详细说说。我想了解更多，因为我花了很多时间跟我妻子讨论，这太棒了。我很兴奋，但，让我们把这个推演下去。而且，我确信如果我想受雇的话，几年后我还是会受雇的。但我绝对不认为我现在的，你知道的，我今天的工作会是什么样子。我认为它会有很大不同。而且我处在一个很好的位置。但就像我只是，你知道的，我们进行了这些哲学讨论，我当时就在想，社会到底是什么。我上次试图和布莱斯（Bryce）讨论这个。但他没听懂我想表达的意思。这就像，你知道的，意义何在？你知道的，就像它还没出来。
out yet. It'll come out probably the next episode about like I was I was talking about conferences and committee meetings and like are they actually like do they serve a purpose and like maybe the purpose is that like it's actually just nice to meet with people in person like yes you know you're wearing your CPP con shirt you go to a conference you do learn something but like really humans crave like social connection and and like you know if a conference was like just the learning aspect and you don't have the hallway track and you don't get to have conversations with people like that's just like a you know, a module that your boss sends you to like stare at for a couple hours. That's not like fulfilling. Like it's much better to go and, and, and have real conversations with real human.
还没发布呢。可能在下一期播客里会发出来，关于我当时在谈论会议和委员会会议，以及它们是否真的，它们是否发挥了作用，也许它的作用是，你知道的，实际上能和人们面对面见面真的很棒，是的，你知道的，你穿着你的CPP con衬衫，你去参加一个会议，你确实学到了一些东西，但真正的人类渴望社交连接，并且，你知道的，如果一个会议只是学习的方面，而你没有走廊闲聊（hallway track），也没有机会和人们交谈，那这就只是一个，你知道的，你的老板派你去盯着看几个小时的模块。那不是充实的。去和真正的真人进行真正的对话要好得多。
Anyways, and so like I'm thinking like if our whole industry falls apart, like, and we're not going to conferences is like, you know, I'm going to just be buying gnomes and putting them in my backyard and pretending to have like a fake conference with like my backyard gnomes? And anyways, over to you on everything I just said in existential crisis and not authoring code. Yeah. So, so for me this. you know, hit pretty hard because Dave Abraham's, who was a member of Software Technology Lab on my team, he really had a pretty strong reaction, anti-AI reaction, and it was like, you know, this is going to destroy the industry. And part of his answer was, was he got involved with
不管怎样，我在想，如果整个行业都分崩离析了，我们也不去参加会议了，你知道的，我打算去买几个花园小矮人，把它们放在后院，假装和它们举行一场假会议。总之，我刚才说的这些存在主义危机和不写代码的话题，就交给你来接话了。是的。所以，对我来说，这触动挺深的，因为戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）——我团队里软件技术实验室的成员——他确实反应非常强烈，对AI持反对态度，他觉得，你知道的，这会毁了这个行业。他的应对方式之一，就是加入
the band, playing music, and retired. And so he and I were working on the better code book in making some solid progress. And I've, since Dave retired, I've done very little with the book because, one, I don't have a collaborator on it every day now. And two, there's this who's going to read it. Right, right. What's the point? The first couple of chapters make a really good prompt. So I have my Claude rule to say, go, go read the start of the book. Wait, this is, this is like you already dropped too massive. First of all, I didn't know that Dave had, did you know, Bryce, that David retired? Yeah, I think we talked about this. Definitely not on this. This is news to me. This is the first, well, unless if I have a bad memory,
了乐队，弹奏音乐，然后退休了。所以他和我一直在合著《更好的代码》这本书，并取得了一些实质性的进展。自从戴夫退休后，我对这本书做的工作就很少了，因为第一，我现在每天没有合作者了；第二，谁会去读它呢？对吧，对吧？有什么意义呢？前几章写得非常适合作为提示词。所以我让我的Claude规则去读这本书的开头。等等，这个信息太震撼了。首先，我不知道戴夫……布赖斯，你知道戴夫退休了吗？是的，我想我们讨论过这个。绝对不是在这个节目里。这对我来说是新闻。这是第一次……好吧，除非我记性不好，
But definitely... You are getting old. So it sounds like partially, if not entirely, the reason that Dave retired was because of AI and where he thought the industry was going? No, I think his primary reason was he had an opportunity to play his music full time. And that's always been a passion of his. So I definitely think that was his primary reason. But I think a secondary reason was just... the same existential crisis of,
但绝对……你确实老了。所以听起来，戴夫退休的部分原因，如果不是全部原因的话，是因为AI以及他所认为的行业发展方向？不，我认为他的主要原因是得到了一个全职演奏音乐的机会。这一直是他的热情所在。所以我绝对认为那是他的主要原因。但我认为次要原因仅仅是……那种同样的存在主义危机，即
he viewed it as, you know, he had built his career on trying to help engineers write better code. And, and what does that mean now? And so I spent my sabbatical, giving a lot of thought to that problem,
在他看来，你知道的，他的职业生涯建立在帮助工程师编写更好的代码之上。那么，现在这意味着什么呢？因此，我把休假时间花在了深入思考这个问题上，
and came to a somewhat different conclusion than Dave came to, which is at the end of the day, I don't, yeah, there's Dave Abrams, his website, it's great. Yeah,
并得出了一个与戴夫截然不同的结论，那就是归根结底，我不……是的，那是戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯的网站，非常棒。是的，
you know, we'll see, he's got some of his, It's really good. We will have to have him on, and hopefully he'll, even though he's retired, he'll be happy to come and tell us his thoughts. There you go. But yeah, on my sabbatical, I spent a lot of time thinking about this issue. And the conclusion I came to was, was I never cared about the people in that equation.
你知道的，我们会拭目以待，他有一些……真的很棒。我们得邀请他来做客，希望他退休后也乐意来跟我们分享他的想法。就是这样。不过话说回来，在休假期间，我花了很多时间思考这个问题。我得出的结论是，我从来不在乎那个等式里的人。
You know, the reason why I've pushed for better code is because I want better code. So back to the LLM as people. If I can get the LLM to write better code, then that's pretty fulfilling. I'll tell you what I think that people like us will be doing, which is I think that people like us will inevitably gravitate towards developing models that are good at coding. Like for somebody who's an experienced software engineer, experienced in programming language and library design and all of these things, somebody who's more on the systems end than on the applied end of software development,
你知道的，我之所以一直推动更好的代码，是因为我想要更好的代码。所以回到把大模型当作人的话题上。如果我能让大模型写出更好的代码，那其实挺有成就感的。我告诉你我觉得像我们这样的人以后会做什么，那就是我们不可避免地会倾向于开发擅长编程的模型。对于一个经验丰富的软件工程师、精通编程语言和库设计以及所有这些东西的人来说，一个更偏向于系统端而不是软件开发应用端的人，
I think like it's just natural that we're all going to gravitate towards model development. I think there's some truth in that. I think that, you know, and from a societal standpoint, that creates an interesting dilemma, right? Those of us with experience will be employed at least for a while as we put ourselves out of business. you know, I also talk to a lot of people in their first comment is, well, software engineering looks like a solved problem. So what are you going to do next? And I'm like, do you have to understand that what software engineers do is we solve other people's problems? So if software engineering is a solved problem, so is everything else, right?
我觉得大家自然而然都会转向模型开发。我觉得这有一定的道理。我认为，从社会的角度来看，这产生了一个有趣的困境，对吧？我们这些有经验的人至少还会被雇用一段时间，直到我们把自己给搞失业。你知道的，我也和很多人交流过，他们的第一反应是，好吧，软件工程看起来像是一个已经解决的问题。那你接下来要做什么？我说，你必须明白，软件工程师做的事情是帮别人解决问题。所以如果软件工程是一个已解决的问题，那其他一切也都是了，对吧？
It will just all tumble. I would say that I think that coding might be a partially solved problem or close. Software engineering, I don't think we're anywhere near to that being a solved problem. Like, show me, show me, show me, show me an AI system that can ship software at scale over the course of multiple years without a human in the loop. I think we're pretty far. Sean has literally said he's about to fork his cell R.S. And say, go solve the outstanding issues. And, you know, if we're not there today, we are very close, Bryce.
一切都会随之崩溃。我想说，我认为编程可能是一个部分解决的问题，或者接近解决。至于软件工程，我认为我们离解决这个问题还十万八千里。比如，给我展示一个、展示一个、展示一个、展示一个能够在多年时间里大规模交付软件而中间不需要人类干预的AI系统。我觉得我们离那还很远。肖恩（Sean）刚才明明说过他准备分叉他的Cell R.S.，然后说去解决那些遗留问题。而且，你知道的，如果我们今天还没达到那个水平，布赖斯，那我们也已经非常接近了。
I know your experience is different, but like three years from now, there's no way that we don't get to a point where large software, or I don't know, maybe Sean, you might disagree. You're not accounting for the long horizon behavior. And as me, somebody who's been exclusively focused on longer horizon behavior, as soon as there is misbehavior, it very quickly becomes a feedback loop. And without really, really strong processes and validation and guard rails, over time, the system becomes more and more incoherent. Yeah, but that's true of people doing engineering too, right? Like, I have people who are like, you know, oh, look at this horrible code the LLM wrote. And I'm like, crack any file in Photoshop and you will find it.
我知道你的经验有所不同，但三年后，我们绝不可能达不到这样一种状态：大型软件……或者我不知道，也许肖恩，你会有所不同。你没有考虑到长期行为。而作为我这样一个专注于长期行为的人来说，一旦出现异常行为，它很快就会变成一个反馈循环。如果没有非常非常强大的流程、验证和防护栏，随着时间的推移，系统就会变得越来越不连贯。是的，但人类做工程也是如此，对吧？比如，我遇到过一些人说：“噢，你看大模型写的那堆可怕的代码。”而我会说：“你在Photoshop里随便打开哪个文件，都能找到这样的代码。”
Right? It's a 30-year-old code base that's been built incremental. and it is at the point where I would say in many ways it's kind of losing coherence, right? There's nobody on the team who can keep the entire project in their head anymore. There hasn't been for 20 years, right? And so I think that it's true of LLMs and it's true of people. And I kind of go back to the failure points are the same. and if you expect to get good results out of an LLM without putting in place the whole process,
对吧？这是一个有30年历史的代码库，是一点点累积起来的。它已经发展到我可以说在很多方面有点失去连贯性的地步了，对吧？团队里已经没有任何一个人能把整个项目装在脑子里了。20年来一直如此，对吧？所以我觉得这既适用于大模型，也适用于人类。我的看法是，失败的点是完全一样的。如果你期望从大模型中获得好结果，却不同时建立起完整的流程，
you're going to be kind of in for a world of pain, right? Right. And yeah, I don't think that having that whole process in some shippable form, like I said, I think Claude Code Codex or some of these other systems are 1.0 system of that, right? We are just in the beginning. I don't have a way even in cloud code to specify a complete engineering process and then deploy that at scale and say, you know, follow this process. But I think that's going to happen really quick. I think there are a number of companies that are working in that direction.
那你可就要吃大苦头了，对吧？没错。而且，是的，我不认为以某种可交付的形式拥有整个流程……就像我说的，我觉得Claude Code、Codex或其中一些其他系统是这方面的1.0版系统，对吧？我们才刚刚开始。即使在Claude Code中，我也没有办法指定一个完整的工程流程，然后将其大规模部署并说“执行这个流程”。但我认为这很快就会发生。我觉得有很多公司正朝着这个方向努力。
I'd be shocked if Open AI and Anthropic and the other big AI vendors, Google, Gemini, are not seeing the same thing and going after the problem. Right. Like I was just reading an article lately that was like, oh, you know, chat GPT is not that smart because we tried to have it run a business, right? And we let it be the boss of the employees. And it did a horrible job. And I'm like, well, yeah, sure. You know, if you hired some random kid off the street and you said, you run this store, we'll just ask you questions you answer. That would be a disaster. And that's effectively what they just did, right? It's like you need the person who's run the store who's got the experience to set up what is the process for running the store and build that into a framework for the AI to follow. But yeah, I don't see that we're going to hit a limit. And I think society, you know, I keep saying between 20 and 40 years, that's still kind of my back of the envelope evolution, although I think we're going faster, so probably closer to 20 years. We're going to hit a point in 20 years or less where the AI can do a better job at any job than a person can. And what does that mean for the societal impact? Right.
如果OpenAI、Anthropic和其他大型AI供应商（如谷歌的Gemini）没有看到这一点并着手解决这个问题，我才会感到震惊呢。没错。就像我最近读到的一篇文章，上面说：“哦，你知道的，ChatGPT其实没那么聪明，因为我们试着让它去经营一家公司，对吧？我们让它当员工的老板。结果它干得一团糟。”而我的反应是：“好吧，当然了。如果你随便从街上招个小孩来，然后对他说‘你来经营这家店，我们问你问题你来回答’，那绝对是一场灾难。”而这实际上正是他们刚才做的事，对吧？这就好比你需要一个有经验、经营过店铺的人来设定店铺的运营流程，并将其构建为供AI遵循的框架。不过话说回来，我不认为我们会触及上限。而且我认为社会——我一直说是20到40年之间——这仍然是我粗略估计的演变周期，不过我觉得我们的进展正在加快，所以可能接近20年。我们在20年或更短的时间内就会达到这样一个节点：AI在任何工作上都能比人类做得更好。这对社会影响意味着什么？对吧？
Right. And it will do it cheaper, pretty much. Yeah. Okay. So, so from picking strawberries to building rocket ships, right? I think it will be doing a better job. So from my standpoint, I'm like assuming society doesn't completely unravel, I'll retire in that time frame. I'm out.
对。而且它做得更便宜，差不多就是这样。没错。所以，从摘草莓到造火箭，对吧？我觉得它都会做得更好。所以从我的角度来看，假设社会没有彻底崩溃，我会在那个时间框架内退休。我撤了。
I was going to say, so Dave's already retired. Sean's going to retire. So it sounds like just try to get yourself financially in a position where you can retire and you'll be good. Yeah, I hope the economy doesn't take so badly that it doesn't destroy your retirement. Yeah, on ST Lab right now our challenges, Dave retired, Mark Hambur retired, Nick DeMarco took a medical leave and then announced he's not coming back. So my team of five is now a team of two, myself and David Sankle. So, hey, that's a pretty good team of two. Is David, uh, talked about retiring?
我正想说，戴夫已经退休了。肖恩也要退休了。所以听起来，只要设法让自己的财务状况达到可以退休的状态，你就万事大吉了。对，我希望经济不要糟糕到毁了你的退休生活。是的，目前在ST Lab我们面临的挑战是，戴夫退休了，马克·汉堡（Mark Hambur）退休了，尼克·德马科（Nick DeMarco）请了病假，然后宣布不回来了。所以我这支五人团队现在缩减成了两人团队——我和大卫·桑克尔（David Sankle）。所以，嘿，这也是个相当不错的两人团队。大卫……他有提过退休的事吗？
No, no, David's not, not talking about it. David, David has like 13 kids and they're about to start entering college age. So I don't think he's going to be. retiring anytime soon? Well, I was on, it's not quite 13, but while I was on 12 or 11 or something. It's 10. It's 10. But is it, but it's 11th coming? No,
没有，没有，大卫没有、没有谈过这事。大卫有大约13个孩子，他们快要到上大学的年龄了。所以我觉得他不会很快退休的。好吧，我当时在……其实没到13个，但当我生到第12个还是第11个左右的时候……是10个。是10个。但是，但是第11个要来了吗？不，
the 10th just came. So while I was on my sabbatical, he had his 10th. So, so he's got stepping off beat by one. So Wow, stepping up has nine kids. Is that right? No, I'm sorry, stepping off his eight kids. He's got stepping off beat by two.
第10个刚刚出生。所以当我休假的时候，他的第10个孩子出生了。所以，所以他……我数差了一个。所以，哇，大卫有9个孩子？是这样吗？不对，对不起，大卫有8个孩子。我数差了两个。
Wow. So, I had no idea. Yeah, yeah. You got to catch up, Connor. You need seven more kids. I mean, we've talked about definitely having two, but there's, I don't know. I think honestly, when I think, I don't even, when I think of eight or ten kids, like, Shima and I have had conversations about how many we want. And I think about it from like a getting on a plane perspective.
哇。所以，我完全不知道。对，对。康纳（Connor），你得加油了。你需要再生七个孩子。我是说，我们确实讨论过肯定要生两个，但是……我不知道。说实话，每当我想到有八个或十个孩子时——我和希玛（Shima）讨论过我们想要几个孩子——我是从坐飞机的角度去考虑的。
Like, if you have two kids when it's like a big plane, it's pretty good because you can sit one parent on each aisle. and then you each directly have access to a kid. As soon as you have a third, you're going to, like, one parent's going to have two kids on either side and then the other one's going to be off. If you got eight or ten, like, I guess you're just not flying,
比如，如果你有两个孩子，坐大飞机时还挺不错的，因为你可以让父母一人坐一条过道，然后你们俩都能直接照顾到一个孩子。一旦你有了第三个孩子，你就会发现……比如一个家长得一边照顾两个孩子，而另一个家长则坐在别处。如果你有八到十个孩子，我想你大概就根本没办法坐飞机了，
because that's like, that's impossible. Well, presumably they're spread out a little bit. So that's where you get to be underwatches and the other ones. Yeah, that's a good point. I didn't think about that. I used to ask David, like, when he was like on kid number seven or eight, I asked him like, oh, like, isn't it hard?
因为那太……那是不可能的。嗯，据推测他们年龄会有所分散。所以这就是大一点的孩子照顾小一点的孩子的时候了。对，这倒是个好主意。我之前没想到这点。我以前问过大卫，当他生到第七或第八个孩子时，我问他：“哦，这不是很辛苦吗？”
And he's like, you know, once you have like a critical mass of them, they sort of like the older ones, take care of the younger ones. And it all sort of works out. I wasn't thinking long enough down the path. Yeah. Anyway, so you're just going to retire. I mean, it's interesting too because like, well, I'm not retiring soon. Yeah, yeah, not retiring yet.
他说：“你知道的，一旦你生了一定数量的孩子，形成规模后，大一点的孩子就会照顾小一点的孩子。事情自然而然就顺了。”我当时没有把眼光放得那么长远。好吧，总之，你就要退休了。我的意思是，这也挺有意思的，因为……嗯，我可不打算很快退休。对，对，还没打算退休呢。
No, he's got, he's got to do the Sean Parent, AI, process, software engineering harness startup. Well, yeah. I mean, right. I would like to finish this run at property models and play that through. And it's kind of part of what I've viewed as a larger vision, which I refer to as declarative forms and this notion that the complexity of software at scale becomes structural and not algorithmic.
不，他得去搞肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）式的AI流程软件工程外挂创业公司。好吧，对。我的意思是，没错。我想完成这次关于属性模型（property models）的开发，并把它贯彻到底。这在某种程度上符合我所设想的宏大愿景，我称之为“声明式表单”（declarative forms），这种理念认为：大规模软件的复杂性应该是结构性的，而不是算法性的。
And so you want to have systems in place where you can describe the structures of systems and have that be a solved problem. So you want to be able to do that declaratively, and that's what I refer to as declarative forms. So you want to start programming at a much higher level when you're building things at scale. And I kind of say, you know, I think within, you know, a typical desktop product, you've got somewhere between a half dozen and a dozen declarative forms in there, and you want a system, you know, you can think of each declarative form as being this declarative DSL that describes it. You want those systems to all be similar syntax and to interoperate.
因此，你需要建立这样的系统：在其中你可以描述系统的结构，并让这成为一个已解决的问题。所以你希望能够以声明式的方式做到这一点，这就是我所说的“声明式表单”。因此，当你在进行大规模构建时，你希望在更高的层面上开始编程。并且我认为，在一个典型的桌面产品中，你大概有半打到一打的声明式表单，你希望有一个系统——你可以把每个声明式表单看作是描述它的声明式DSL（领域特定语言）。你希望这些系统都具有相似的语法并且能够互操作。
So I can be like, okay, well, I've described the parser for parsing the file, and that's going to map into a schema for a database, and I'm going to attach a UI, and that's going to have a layout engine, and that's going to have a behavioral engine, and you're going to have this set of DSLs, and they're all going to be the piping in kind of a functional language from one to the other to communicate and build your complete. system. So, so, you know, I'd like to, property models for me are kind of, you know, the first step in that, the first piece of that system that I want to build. And so I'd like to carry that out. I do want to finish the book. I'm not sure what form it's going to take now. You know, maybe at
这样我就可以说：好吧，我已经描述了解析文件的解析器，它将映射到数据库的模式（schema），然后我要附加一个UI，它将有一个布局引擎，它将有一个行为引擎，你将拥有一套DSL，它们将通过某种函数式语言相互连接、互相沟通，从而构建出你的完整系统。所以，你知道的，属性模型对我要构建的那个系统来说，是第一步，也是其中的第一个组件。因此我想把它贯彻到底。我确实想把这本书写完。我只是还不确定它最终会以什么形式呈现。也许在
some point I'll have the energy to pick it up and continue where we left it. How close to being done do you think it is? Oh, it's, we've got, you know, two solid chapters, two chapters in progress, and the book is slated to be probably eight chapters, right? So it's somewhere between a quarter and a third of the way done, I would say. Maybe for episode 400, we can launch the Sean Parent book tour. Here we go. Maybe so. It's tough because my key collaborators on that were Dave and Nick.
某个时刻，我会恢复精力，重新拾起它，从我们中断的地方继续写下去。你觉得离完工还有多远？哦，我们已经写好了……有两章非常扎实，还有两章正在进行中，这本书预计大概会有八章，对吧？所以我大概完成了四分之一到三分之一吧。也许到了第400期节目，我们可以启动“肖恩·帕伦特图书巡回签售会”呢。说不定还真行。这挺不容易的，因为我在这方面的核心合作者是戴夫和尼克。
and I'm trying to convince Sankle to partner with me on it. I'm like, I have learned over the year that I'm much like Alex, which is it is very hard for me to stay focused on writing anything because I get started on it, and then I see all of these tangents, and then I've got to go build a bunch of code. So I need a collaborator to make progress. I have a similar problem.
而我正试图说服桑克尔跟我合作。我常说：过去这一年我学到的一点是，我和亚历克斯很像，那就是我很难专注于写任何东西，因为我一旦开始写，就会看到各种各样延伸出去的分支，然后我就得跑去写一堆代码。所以我需要一个合作者来取得进展。我也遇到了类似的问题。
So distracted by Lint, basically. I was also going to mention, have you heard of, have you heard of Lean? When you were talking about the property model and the constraint system, I was thinking about, you know, formal verification is like all the rage these days. Yeah. And everybody's talking about lean. I haven't really looked at it that much, but, you know, it's this language for expressing proofs, but also kind of just a programming language, too.
基本上就是被 Lint 搞得很分心。我還想提一下，你有聽過、你有聽過 Lean 嗎？當你在談論屬性模型和約束系統時，我就在想，你知道的，形式化驗證現在非常流行。對啊。每個人都在談論 Lean。我其實沒有深入研究過它，但你知道的，這是一門用來表達證明的語言，但某種程度上它也算是一種程式語言。
Yeah, I haven't played with Lean yet. It's on my list of things to play. with, I have played with Daphne, which is a similar programming system. I like Daphne. There are problems with trying to build systems at scale that are formally verified, but they're nice in the small. I think LLMs will help with the scalability problem there. I've had good luck with Daphne with LLMs completing proofs for me, which is, you know,
對，我還沒玩過 Lean。它在我的待辦清單上，我有空會玩玩看。我玩過 Daphne，這是一個類似的程式系統。我滿喜歡 Daphne 的。嘗試大規模建構經過形式化驗證的系統會有一些問題，但它們在小規模時表現很好。我覺得大型語言模型將有助於解決那裡的擴展性問題。我用 Daphne 時運氣不錯，大型語言模型幫我完成了證明，這你知道的，
I'll get stuck and it'll be like, oh, hey, you just need to put this assertion in and you're good. And I think that's because in any of these systems, the LLMs have only trained off of correct proofs because that's all anything ever, you know, nobody's code into GitHub that doesn't compile. And within a formal verification system, compiling means it checks. And so the LLMs have like only ever seen correct proofs. And so know the rules for how to get there. Although that may not be true because I think there are some models specifically designed for theorem proving. Like I think Deep Seek had a approver model and presumably they did reinforcement learning. And so during the reinforcement learning process, the model would have written bad proofs and then learned, oh, you know, here's how I can write a better one.
我會卡住，然後它就會說：「噢，嘿，你只需要把這個斷言放進去，就沒問題了。」我認為這是因為在任何這些系統中，大型語言模型只根據正確的證明進行過訓練，因為這就是所有的東西，你知道的，沒有人會把無法編譯的程式碼提交到 GitHub 上。在形式化驗證系統中，編譯意味著它通過了檢查。所以大型語言模型只見過正確的證明。因此它知道如何到達那裡的規則。儘管這可能不完全正確，因為我認為有些模型是專門為定理證明設計的。就像我記得 DeepSeek 有一個證明器模型，想必他們做過強化學習。所以在強化學習的過程中，模型可能會寫出糟糕的證明，然後學到：「噢，你知道的，這是我可以寫出更好證明的方法。」
That actually, I would not be surprised if that's in, to some degree, in the, like, you know, post-training recipe for the big frontier models, too. Yeah, I'd be a little surprised because I don't know that they've gotten to the point yet where they're doing, you know, post-training on proving systems correct. But maybe they're starting to, at least on the math front. Yeah, I would guess that specifically that they're doing it now because of this, like, arms race in. cracking the world's math problems. Yeah, yeah. I lost my train of thought. Where were we going with this conversation?
說實話，如果大型前沿模型的後訓練配方中在某種程度上也包含了這個，我一點也不會感到意外。對，我會稍微有點驚訝，因為我不知道它們是否已經到了那種地步，就是對證明系統是否正確進行後訓練。但或許它們正開始這樣做，至少在數學領域是如此。對，我猜它們具體就是現在在這樣做，因為這是一場破解世界數學難題的軍備競賽。對啊對啊。我忘記剛才要說什麼了。我們這段對話本來要講到哪裡？
We were just talking about the... Yeah. I think really the question was about the applicability of formal verification methods to these property models and the constraint checking. Oh, yeah, definitely true in that, you know, I've been doing a fair amount of... I haven't formally verified the algorithms behind them, But the idea with property models is they prove a bunch of attributes on your system.
我們剛剛在談論……對。我覺得真正的問題其實是關於形式化驗證方法對這些屬性模型和約束檢查的適用性。噢，對，這絕對是真的，你知道的，我一直在做相當多的……我沒有對背後的演算法進行形式化驗證，但屬性模型的理念是它們證明了你系統上的一堆屬性。
And one of the tasks that I have outstanding is to build an analyzer where everything that I can't prove it directly in the compiler, I've got this growing kind of analyzer task, which is I want to build a model checker after the fact that we'll do a deeper analysis to verify the correctness of your model. Yeah. And I think a lot of these systems fall into some form of a multi-way constraint system. it's just that the shapes of those
我待辦的任務之一，就是建構一個分析器；對於所有我無法直接在編譯器中證明的東西，我有一個不斷增加的分析器任務，也就是我想在事後建構一個模型檢查器，來做更深入的分析，以驗證你的模型的正確性。對。而且我認為這些系統中的許多都屬於某種形式的多路約束系統，只不過這些系統的形狀
tend to be very different. So a layout engine is a multi-way constraint system, but it's trying to minimize a set of constraints. And you have scheduling multi-way constraint systems where you put a strength on constraint so you can say, well, this person doesn't have to be at the meeting. So I'd like them to be, but if you can't find a slot,
往往非常不同。所以排版引擎是一個多路約束系統，但它試圖最小化一組約束。你還有排程多路約束系統，在這種系統中，你為約束設定了強度，所以你可以說，嗯，這個人不需要出席會議。所以我希望他們能出席，但如果你找不到空檔，
break that constraint and let them out. Property models are a multi-way constraint system, but all the constraints have to be satisfied. and the strength applies to the values within the system. So you can override a value and derive it or not based off the strength of the values. So a lot of these systems have similar structure, but to solve a particular problem in this particular domain, you have kind of this larger set of constraints the layers on top.
就打破那個約束，讓他們離開。屬性模型是一個多路約束系統，但所有的約束都必須被滿足，而強度則應用於系統中的數值。因此，你可以根據數值的強度來覆蓋某個數值並衍生出它，或者不這麼做。所以其中許多系統都有類似的結構，但為了在這個特定領域解決特定問題，你會有更大的一組層疊在最上面的約束。
And that's also where I think a lot of people get stuck, right? They try to say, well, I can just build a generalized constraint, solve all these problems. And the answer is probably not, right? It's, you know, in the same way, like, or you make it touring complete. You know, you reinvent protocol. And it's like, well, sure, you can, but is it the right system to solve the problem? Yeah. So, yeah, but that's what I'd like to continue to do.
這也是我認為很多人卡住的地方，對吧？他們試圖說：「嗯，我可以只建構一個廣義的約束來解決所有這些問題。」而答案很可能是不行，對吧？這是，你知道的，用同樣的方式，或者你把它搞成了圖靈完備。你知道的，你重新發明了協議。這就像是，好吧，當然你可以這麼做，但這是解決問題的正確系統嗎？對。所以，對，但這就是我想繼續做的事情。
You know, the question is, how much runway do I get at Adobe? Like I said, my research team is down to two of us. We haven't gotten back fills. We're in Titus's org, which has gone through some significant reorganizations. So, you know, I might end up back assisting the Photoshop team or something. And go back to my evening project, we'll have to see. Well, hopefully, hopefully we don't have to have a third resurrection of the SD lab. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
問題是，我在 Adobe 還能有多少自主權？就像我說的，我的研究團隊只剩下兩個人了。我們一直沒有補到缺。我們在 Titus 的組織底下，該組織經歷了一些重大的組織重組。所以，你知道的，我最後可能會回去協助 Photoshop 團隊或之類的。然後回到我晚上的專案，我們拭目以待。嗯，希望我們不需要經歷 SD 實驗室的第三次復活。對啊對啊對啊。
I think we're in many ways, this is kind of the end of the second resurrection. So, yeah, that's unfortunate. Hopefully the rejoining. Did that work? It did indeed. Yes. This is a perfect way to segue back to when you were saying, open up any file of Photoshop, you know, and we can see it's like,
我覺得在許多方面，這算是第二次復活的結束。所以，嗯，這很不幸。希望重新加入。那樣管用嗎？確實管用。沒錯。這是完美的方式，可以轉回你剛才說的，打開 Photoshop 的任何檔案，你知道的，我們就能看到，就像是
I went on this rant in the last episode about how, you know, I referenced this little clip all the time, Jonathan Blow, who's a, you know, game designer. He in the middle of a 60-minute talk went on like an eight-minute tyrant. of like everything he noticed that was wrong with like software he was using and he was he said he planned on doing it for a week but then like he ran out of like space in his deck in like a day and a half of just all the different things and like I've I've told a few people this over the last like month is that now that AI is here and it can like do everything and it's it made me
我在上一集裡長篇大論了一番，你知道的，我一直提到這個小片段，就是遊戲設計師喬納森·布洛（Jonathan Blow）。他在一個 60 分鐘演講的過程中，進行了大約 8 分鐘的猛烈抨擊，
realize like how bad software is because now I'm just like like you can just get the AI to fix it and we have internalized dealing with poor quality software, like all the time. But fixing it will introduce new problems. That's the thing. It's like when Sean was talking about, like when he was working on CloudCo getting it, he said, oh, by the way, you know, I also noticed three issues. Like if you just open up, you know, Claude Opus, whatever your version is or Codex,
痛斥他注意到自己使用的軟體中所有出錯的地方，他說他本來打算講一個禮拜，結果在一點半的時間內，他的簡報空間就用完了，全都是各種不同的問題。就像我過去一個月左右向幾個人提到的一樣，既然人工智慧已經來了，而且它幾乎無所不能，這讓我
and you say, I've noticed an issue. Also, by the way, can you just like take a look and see if there's any other things? And it'll go and like say, oh, I noticed you're using this open source thing for cross-platform mobile development and it has a bunch of known issues and I went and checked to see if you were exposed to those and I noticed you were like it might have been might not have been causing issues but I went and had and like coded in some safeguards just to make sure you don't hit that stuff it's like no programmer I know has the capacity to do that like in a week let alone in five minutes like it just went in like consumed everything yeah but fixed my issue sometimes those sometimes those safeguards
意識到軟體有多爛，因為現在我只會覺得——就像你可以直接叫人工智慧去修復它一樣，而我們一直以來都在內部默默忍受著品質低劣的軟體。但修復它會引入新的問題。就是這樣。就像尚（Sean）在談論的時候，當他正在處理 CloudCo 的程式碼並將其搞定時，他說：「噢，順便告訴你，我也注意到了三個問題。」如果你直接打開，你知道的，Claude Opus、無論你用的是哪個版本或 Codex，
are like the wrong safeguard no no no no GPT 5.6 doesn't let me down. What are you going to say, Sean? Yeah. First, I agree with the sentiment. It's like I can't use any piece of software for more than 10 minutes without, you know, having some gripe, right? This is wrong. This feature is broken. This thing drives me nuts.
然後你說：「我注意到了一個問題。順便問一下，你能順便看一下有沒有其他問題嗎？」它就會進去看並說：「噢，我注意到你正在為跨平臺行動開發使用這個開源東西，它有很多已知的問題，我去看了一下你是否暴露在這些問題中，我發現你的確是——它可能已經造成了問題，也可能沒有，但我還是寫了一些防護措施，以確保你不會遇到那些麻煩。」這就像，我認識的任何程式設計師都沒有能力在一週內做到那種事，更不用說在五分鐘內了——它就直接進去，把所有東西都消化了。對，但幫我修復了問題。有時候那些——有時候那些防護措施
And for the record, I might clean it up a little bit. Sean's audio stopped working and then he dropped out of the call, rejoined the call, and magically his audio started working again. Thanks for talking about. Software sucks. And Dave Abraham had what he referred to as A-Block, Abraham's first law of computing, which is computers, no damn good. Oh, yes. So just for context here, I've had the LLM start sending PRs for my new histokash algorithm to Cub.
就像是錯誤的防護措施。不，不，不，不，GPT 5.6 從不讓我失望。你剛剛想說什麼，尚？對。首先，我同意這種情緒。這就像我無法使用任何軟體超過 10 分鐘，而不會（你知道的）有些抱怨，對吧？這裡錯了。這個功能壞了。這東西快把我逼瘋了。
And it's broken it up into four PRs. The first PR, I just earlier today gave the check of a, approval after and the GitHub PR thread it has 433 comments because I've been iterating on it for two weeks of cleaning up this like plus plus 1800 minus 800 lines of code diff and I didn't read every line of code you know I'm mostly skimmed and then like read its comments but it took a lot of iteration to get it from its initial PR to something that I think can land. Now, the people who are the actual Cub maintainers now have to sign off on it, so it'll probably be a more review after that.
為了記錄在案，我可能會稍微清理一下。尚的音訊停止運作，然後他掉出了通話，重新加入了通話，神奇的是他的音訊又開始運作了。謝謝你談論。軟體爛透了。戴夫·亞伯拉罕（Dave Abraham）有一個他稱為 A-Block 的理論，即亞伯拉罕計算第一定律，也就是電腦，沒一個好東西。噢，沒錯。所以為了提供一些背景資訊，我讓大型語言模型開始為我的新 histokash 演算法向 Cub 發送 PR。
There's probably things that I missed. I definitely think... I would look at this and say, you know, first, that's a huge PR that no person would want to review. And second, it's like, what are your rules that built that PR? It's like, is there a spec behind it that got written first? are their unit tests for it they got written first? Why wasn't it phased out into a multi-phased implementation at that scale?
它把它拆成了四個 PR。第一個 PR，我剛剛在今天稍早給予了批准，在 GitHub PR 討論串中它有 433 條評論，因為我已經迭代了兩個星期，在清理這大約增加了 1800 行、刪除了 800 行程式碼的差異。我並沒有閱讀每一行程式碼，你知道的，我基本上只是瀏覽了一下，然後閱讀它的評論，但它確實需要很多次迭代，才能從最初的 PR 變成我認為可以合併的狀態。現在，身為 Cub 實際維護者的那些人必須簽署同意，所以在那之後可能還會有更多的審查。
But I think plus 2,000 minus or plus 1,800 minus 800 lines of code is not too bad. It's not too large. That's definitely in the category. Like everybody knows the anecdote of like the three different sizes. And it's like, you know, if it's too small, you get too many comments or whatever, blah, blah, blah. But like if it's big enough, people are like LGTTM, you know, you can just. You can ship it. And I'm sure our engineers won't do that.
可能有些東西我漏掉了。我絕對認為……我看到這個會說，你知道的，首先，這是一個沒人想審查的巨大 PR。其次，就是說，建構那個 PR 的規則是什麼？這就像，背後是不是有一份先寫好的規格？是不是有先寫好的單元測試？為什麼在那個規模下沒有把它分階段實施？
We got a great folks over on the CCCL team and they will review it. But definitely it's like the bike shedding. You know, you change one little thing and five lines of code and you've got like 10 different people weighing in on. I'm like, well, I don't know about that. Right. So, yeah. So that would be the thing of like, like, you know, why did it get to a PR?
但我認為增加 2,000 行、刪除或增加 1,800 行、減少 800 行程式碼還不算太糟。不算太大。這絕對屬於那個範疇。就像每個人都知道關於三種不同大小的軼事。這就像是，你知道的，如果它太小，你會得到太多的評論之類的，拉巴拉巴。但如果它夠大，人們就會說「我看了覺得沒問題（LGTTM）」，你知道的，你就可以直接發布了。我確信我們的工程師不會那樣做。
What was your process? They got it to the point where a PR were you still had mistakes on it. And all of your criticism in there that you went into that. PR, did you put that back into the system as rules of some form so that these mistakes don't happen again? Yeah, I mean, a lot of it, a lot of it was just not doing things in a way that was consistent with the unwritten coding guidelines of the project. Well, then that's a place where what you want to do is say, you know, go analyze the coding guidelines for my project and write the undocumented ones, right? Yeah, like, it got like a lot like, the latest round of things.
CCCL 團隊有很棒的夥伴，他們會進行審查的。但這絕對就像是在擦皮鞋（譯註：比喻無謂的爭論）。你知道的，你改了一小處地方、五行程式碼，然後就會有 10 個不同的人發表意見。我就會想，嗯，我不確定這個。對吧。所以，嗯。所以那會是這樣的情況：為什麼它會變成一個 PR？
was just like inconsistent naming choices and stuff like that. But like the biggest problem was just like the way that it did the custom, like the tuning policy was just completely wrong. And like a mess and spread across multiple files and not structured. And there were a lot of things where like it added like a new constructor for something. And I was like, why do we need to have a new constructor for this? And like it added like a new mode for something. And so then this like class template now had like three bulls.
你的流程是什麼？它讓 PR 達到了這種程度，而你在上面仍然有錯誤。你在那個 PR 中投入的所有批評，你是否有把這些作為某種形式的規則回饋到系統中，以便這些錯誤不會再次發生？對，我的意思是，很多、很多都只是因為做事情的方式與專案中不成文的編碼準則不一致。好吧，那麼這時候你想做的事就是說，你知道的，「去分析我專案的編碼準則，並寫出那些未記錄的準則」，對吧？對，就像它有很多——最新一輪的事情
where you needed to understand like the right combination of them equaled like one mode and another combination equaled another mode and I'm like, no, no, no, take out those bullions, just give it like an enum that's like, you know, you explicitly tell it what the mode is.
就只是命名選擇不一致之類的事情。但最大的問題只是它編寫自訂調整策略的方式完全錯誤。這簡像個爛攤子，散布在多個檔案中，而且沒有結構。有很多地方它為某個東西新增了一個新的建構子，然後我就會想：「為什麼我們需要為這個新增一個新的建構子？」它還為某個東西新增了一種新模式，所以這個類別範本現在有了三個布林值，
And just a lot of like, like, the way that the abstractions were designed. A lot of the way that abstractions were designed was just not good. And this, I agree, the whole reason why it took so long is that our coding guidelines aren't sufficiently written down and we don't have sufficient ways to actually measure all of those design
你需要理解它們正確的組合等於某種模式，而另一種組合等於另一種模式，而我會說：不，不，不，把那些布林值拿掉，只要給它一個列舉（enum），就像是，你知道的，你明確告訴它模式是什麼。
principles and like I would like to I would like for there to have been a way for a deterministic tool to have flagged these problems like it doesn't need to it like it can have false positives but a lot of these things are things that I think a deterministic tool could have could have flagged as like this is poor quote quote right my normal process for that is is to say okay so you know analyze this and try to distill out what the set of rules are. So at least we have a document where they're written down. And then that gives you a place to start to make corrections. Right, right?
還有很多像是——抽象概念被設計的方式。很多抽象概念被設計的方式就是不好。我同意，整個過程花這麼長時間的根本原因，就是我們的編碼準則沒有被充分寫下來，而且我們沒有足夠的方法來實際衡量所有這些設計
So now at least you've got a point in the system where you're not having an ongoing argument about, well, this is wrong. Why are you making the same mistake? It's, you know, it wasn't written down. Well, I don't want to take the time to write it down. Don't take the time to write it down. AI write it down. That gives you a concrete point where you can say,
原則。我希望——我希望有一個方法可以讓確定性工具標記出這些問題。它不需要——它可以有誤報，但其中許多事情我認為確定性工具是可以標記出來的，像是「這引號引起來很糟對吧」。我通常的處理流程是說，好吧，所以（你知道的）「分析這個，並試圖提煉出規則集是什麼」。所以至少我們有一份文件把它們寫了下來。然後這會給你一個開始進行修正的起點。對吧，對吧？
go add this rule or fix that rule. That's a good idea. I will try that. Yeah. And then like CloudCode has this thing called doctor, and you can use that to kind of distill it down. And one thing the doctor will occasionally suggest, and I have it augmented with my own rule,
所以現在至少你在系統中有了一個著力點，你不會一直在爭論「嗯，這是不對的。你為什麼一直在犯同樣的錯誤？」。因為那沒有被寫下來。好吧，我不想花時間把它寫下來。那就不要花時間寫，讓 AI 把它寫下來。這會給你一個具體的著力點，讓你可以說：
it's like if there's, you know, if you've got instructions in here on how to do something, and you could write a tool for it, like Python or something and save me tokens, go write the tool, right? somebody at invidia has a skill for that it's called determinize where it looks through your your skill and lives out the deterministic parts of the parts that'll save you tokens i listen to i literally just tweeted out and whatever promoted on lincoln a clip from an interview
「去新增這個規則」或「修復那個規則」。這主意不錯。我會試試看。對。然後像 CloudCode 有個叫做 doctor 的東西，你可以用它來進行提煉。doctor 有時會建議的一件事——我用我自己的規則增強了它——
with anders houseberg creator of i believe both typescript and c sharp and potentially a couple other programming languages and like i feel like this is a thing that anyone that spend any amount of time. Like, it's an unlock. Like, and the way he phrased it is, you want to park the stochasticness and then like unlock determinism because these things are non-deterministic, or he would use the word stochastic. If we just let AI loose on, you know, what is it, like a half million lines of code we have in the old compiler or somewhere between half a million and a million, right? And asked it to translate it all. Well, I don't know that that would absolve us from then having go in and carefully examine.
就像是如果這裡面有（你知道的）關於如何做某事的指令，而且你可以為它寫一個工具，像是用 Python 或之類的來幫我節省 Token，那就去寫那個工具，對吧？Nvidia 的某個人有一種針對這個的技能，叫做 determinize（確定化），它會瀏覽你的技能，並剔除確定性的部分——那些能幫你節省 Token 的部分。我聽了——我剛剛才在 LinkedIn 上發布並推廣了一段採訪剪輯，
every line that came out of it to make sure that there were no hallucinations, right? Unless you have 100% perfect test coverage, you probably still got to go check all of that. Now, I think a better approach, quite honestly, would be enlist AI to write a program that helps you translate from TypeScript to go. Because at that point, you can part the stochasticness in that program, and then you can get deterministic behavior whenever you run the program, which means you get the same transformation every time you run it, right? That's always the thing about AI that people forget. It's not deterministic, right? So you can't really trust that it's going to do the same thing twice. Anytime you can get it to write a thing that will then do something deterministically, like one, it's no longer costing you any money, but two, like you're unlocking determinism and like avoiding the non-determinism.
採訪對象是 Anders Hejlsberg，我相信他同時也是 TypeScript 和 C# 的建立者，可能還有其他幾種程式語言。我覺得這是一件任何花費了一定時間的人都會懂的事。這是一個解鎖。他表達的方式是，你想要封存隨機性，然後解鎖確定性，因為這些東西是非確定性的，或者他會使用「隨機性（stochastic）」這個詞。如果我們只是放任 AI 去處理——你知道的，我們在舊編譯器中有大約五十萬行程式碼，或者介於五十萬到一百萬行之間，對吧——並要求它全部翻譯。嗯，我不知道這是否能免除我們隨後必須進去仔細檢查
And like that is a huge unlock. Like I have a ton of workflows that now just are just scripts that just run that like initially AI wrote. but now like AI never touches it and it just is humming along and opening PRs for me and I click merge buttons and like I reviewed every once in a while just to make sure but I feel like it's small things like these that I don't know like if you're trying to get people that are less technical to use this stuff they're not thinking like they don't like my actually my my brother-in-law is like trying to write some software for his company and he works in like the H-FAC business and I think to him
其中出來的每一行程式碼，以確保沒有幻覺，對吧？除非你有 100% 完美的測試覆蓋率，否則你可能還是得去檢查所有這些。現在，老實說，我認為更好的方法是招募 AI 來編寫一個程式，幫助你將 TypeScript 翻譯成 Go。因為在那一點上，你可以封存那個程式中的隨機性，然後每當你執行該程式時，你就能獲得確定性的行為，這意味著你每次執行它都會得到相同的轉換，對吧？這就是 AI 始終讓人忘記的地方。它不是確定性的，對吧？所以你不能真正相信它會做兩次相同的事情。任何時候，只要你能讓它編寫一個能夠以確定性方式執行某些事情的東西，一方面它不再花你任何錢，另一方面，就像你解鎖了確定性並避免了非確定性。
I had to really explain like he's just like oh let's just get AI to do it let's get AI to do it and it's all just like functions to him are all the same thing. And like to me, it's like, okay, if we can not depend on AI for this, that is better. Like when we need to do some optical character recognition or like analyze this photo, okay, we'll hit a Gemini endpoint or a codex endpoint or whatever. But like if we can do this deterministically with some kind of formula, that is so much better from like a simplicity because like every once in a while, the AI is going to get it wrong.
這是一個巨大的解鎖。我有很多工作流程現在只是執行腳本，最初是 AI 寫的，但現在 AI 永遠不會碰它，它只是在順暢地運行並為我開啟 PR，我點擊合併按鈕，就像我偶爾審查一次以確保萬無一失一樣。但我感覺像這樣的小事情，我不知道——如果你試圖讓技術較不熟練的人使用這些東西，他們的思考方式就不一樣——我的——其實我小舅子正試圖為他的公司寫一些軟體，他在 HVAC（暖通空調）業務工作，我想對他來說，
And then he's just like, well, why is it wrong? How come the AI is wrong? I thought AI supposed to be good. And I'm just like, well, you know, we need to minimize that, like, non-deterministic footprint that exists in our software program. And anyways, that's like, yeah, I feel like this is a thing that, like, has been sitting in the back of my head. And I didn't really, until you've just said it, Sean, and then I heard it on this other podcast,
我真的必須解釋——他只是覺得：「噢，我們就叫 AI 做吧，我們就叫 AI 做吧。」對他來說，所有的函式都是一樣的東西。對我來說，這就像是，好吧，如果我們能不依賴 AI 來做這個，那是更好的。當我們需要做一些光學字元辨識或分析這張照片時，好吧，我們會呼叫 Gemini 端點或 Codex 端點或任何東西。但如果我們能用某種公式以確定性方式做到這一點，從簡單性來看要好得多——因為偶爾 AI 會弄錯。
this, yeah, like, turn things into deterministic scripts. Like, it's so much better. Yes. So I saw this great talk at this, at Goson, Paris. It was actually this presentation of this technical report. and they presented this idea that there's these three different software paradigms now. There's traditional software, which has always existed. That's where the reusable form of that is the source code.
然後他就會說：「嗯，為什麼它錯了？為什麼 AI 會錯？我以為 AI 應該很厲害。」而我只會說：「嗯，你知道的，我們需要最小化我們軟體程式中存在的那個非確定性足跡。」不管怎樣，這就像是——是的，我覺得這是一直在我腦海中盤旋的事情。直到你剛剛說了出來，尚，然後我又在另一個播客裡聽到這個，
And it's deterministic, but not flexible. And then you have what they called instant software, which is where you're just prompting the AI, right? And so that is flexible, but it's not deterministic. And the thing that everybody's now starting to do is what they call elastic software, which is somewhere in the middle where you have a combination of source code and scripts and also skills. And that is the benefit that it is somewhat deterministic because parts of it are deterministic, but it's also flexible.
這——是的，就像把事情變成確定性腳本一樣。這好太多了。對。所以我看到這場在巴黎 Goson 的精彩演講。其實這是對一份技術報告的展示，
And the example I keep giving is when I started doing all my auto research work, I created a skill to do an export from a particular VM that I was using. And like 90% of the time, it would do everything I wanted and it would export it in the schema that I wanted. But like, you know, five or 10% of the time, it would do things a little bit different or it would call them, it would give slightly different file names, you know, because just it decided the random noise and the model response decided to do something a little bit different than it did the other, the rest of the time. And so what I did, I could just write a script instead, but if I just wrote a script to do the export, then, well, what if the node was, you know,
他們提出了這樣一個觀點：現在有三種不同的軟體範式。傳統軟體一直都存在。那是可重複使用形式的原始碼。
out of disk space, or what if it couldn't, you know, reach the place where it was supposed to export the data to? Or what if there was some file that the script didn't back up because it didn't know about, but was actually really important to back up? So if you instead have your deterministic export script, and then you have a skill that wraps it that drives the script and also goes and checks whether there's anything that was missing or something, then you sort of get the best of both the world where you get the flexibility and you get the determinism. It's definitely an unlock to get to the point where you can say, okay, you know, we're doing this repeatedly.
它是確定性的，但缺乏靈活性。然後是你所說的即時軟體（instant software），也就是你單純在提示 AI，對吧？所以那是靈活的，但不是確定性的。而現在每個人都開始在做的事，被稱為彈性軟體（elastic software），它介於中間，結合了原始碼、腳本以及技能。這樣的好處是它在某種程度上是確定性的，因為部分是確定性的，但它也是靈活的。
So it seems like we can just write this as a script now. Do that. I was also going to say, you know, around the process standpoint, like I've got this thing. I posted in Slack the other day where I just saw it scrolling by in the in cloud code and the noise. And it was like, oh, I gave this task to A. agent one and agent one claims success but their their description of their of what they did makes no sense so I looked like so so I looked and they you know agent
我一直在舉的例子是，當我開始做所有自動化研究工作時，我建立了一個技能來從我正在使用的特定虛擬機器進行匯出。大約 90% 的時間裡，它會做所有我想要的事，並以我想要的結構描述進行匯出。但大約 5% 或 10% 的時間裡，它會把事情做得有點不同，或者它會呼叫它們——它會給出稍微不同的檔名，你知道的，因為隨機雜訊和模型回應的決定，讓它做出了與其他時間稍微不同的事情。所以我能怎麼做？我可以直接寫一個腳本來代替，但如果我只是寫一個腳本來進行匯出，那麼——好吧，如果節點是
one didn't commit any code to get and and yet claims they completed what they were doing and it kind of goes on like this and it comes back and goes like like okay agent one is just completely hallucinating I'm killing agent one and assigning this task to a new agent and I like I And, you know, if you're using these AI systems as kind of a one-off shot, any kind of harnessing in place to have the agents reviewing what they're doing, you hit these states where you're like, like, oh, okay, well, you know, 90% of the time it's doing what I want, but 10% of the time is just so far off in the weeds, I'm lost, and it's, I kind of refer to it as,
磁碟空間不足，或者如果它無法（你知道的）連線到它應該匯出資料的地方呢？或者如果有一些腳本沒有備份的檔案，因為它不知道，但實際上非常重要而需要備份呢？因此，如果你改為擁有一個確定性的匯出腳本，然後你有一個包裹它的技能來驅動該腳本，同時還會去檢查是否有任何遺失的東西之類的，那麼你就可以兼顧兩者的優勢，既獲得了靈活性，又獲得了確定性。達到這種程度絕對是一個解鎖，你可以說：好吧，你知道的，我們正在重複做這件事。
it's double-check bookkeeping, right, right? Why do accountants keep, you know, everything is a, is a, a credit and a debit and basically you keep, you know, two tables going. And that's because if you make a mistake in one, you will see there's a contradiction. I didn't get the same result. So therefore, there's a mistake somewhere in there. And in what you're building, you want to make sure that your process is set up so that you're not relying on any piece of your system, just getting it right with no double check. Right. I think we're going to, we're going to see this more and more of these kind of like live self-healing systems that are some percentage of like,
所以看起來我們現在可以把它寫成一個腳本了。那就去做吧。我還想說的是，你知道的，從流程的角度來看，我有這樣一個東西。我前幾天在 Slack 上發文，當時我只是看著它在 CloudCode 和噪音中滾動過去。內容是這樣的：「噢，我把這個任務交給了代理一（agent one），代理一聲稱成功了，但他們對自己所做事情的描述根本說不通。」所以我看了——所以我看了，他們（你知道的）代理一
you know, 98% deterministic and it's just, it's just running, you know, but every once in a while there's some crash or some thing or some outage. I'm not sure if either of you run anything off of GitHub pages, but GitHub pages has become, or just GitHub in general, has become like so much more unreliable because everyone's doing what I'm doing, which is like it's free compute, right? Like GitHub actions, I never knew how to write GitHub action code or I don't even know the language. I think it's just YAML. But like you can set up cron jobs and a ton of stuff. But like now because everyone's doing it, their servers are falling over.
沒有向 git 提交任何程式碼，卻聲稱他們已經完成了正在做的事，而且情況一直這樣下去，然後它回來並說——就像是：好吧，代理一完全在產生幻覺，我要終止代理一，並將這個任務指派給一個新的代理。我——而且，你知道的，如果你把這些 AI 系統當作一次性的小玩意來使用，任何用來讓代理審查自己所做工作的約束機制，你都會碰到這樣的狀態：「噢，好吧，你知道的，90% 的時間它都在做我想要的事，但 10% 的時間它偏離軌道太遠了，我迷失了方向，它——我有點把它稱為：
And so like once every four days, like my cron jobs that are running on GitHub actions like fail. And I'm like, okay, like we push the servers over again. But it's like at some point they're going to set it up so that, you know, the same way that Amazon and AWS like figured out elastic compute and they scaled stuff up. like it's going to be the same thing with these software like whenever there's an issue things automatically get like spun out and they're like what's the issue and they're going to diagnose it instantly and not only are they going to fix it but they're going to like harden the system of like okay well what what went wrong here and like i have this like i know it's a utopic you know maybe it's extropian you know look at like the future of software but like even
複式簿記（double-check bookkeeping），對吧，對吧？為什麼會計師要保留——每一筆都是借方和貸方，基本上你要維護兩張表。這是因為如果你在其中一個中犯了錯，你會發現存在矛盾。你沒有得到相同的結果。因此，這裡面某個地方有錯誤。在你建構的東西中，你希望確保你的設定流程是這樣的：你不會依賴系統中的任何部分在沒有複查的情況下就做對。對吧。我想我們將會看到——我們將會看到越來越多這種即時自我修復的系統，它們具有某個百分比的
and i i swear to god i must be projecting but there was this small bug in youtube where i have the a little speed up and the shortcut is shift, you know, comma and shift period to like slow down and up the speed of your video. But if you ever hit pause and then play again, it resets to one, which is like not the end of the world, but it's kind of irritating because it's like shift and then usually four more hits to get to 2.0 times speed, which is basically how I watch all my YouTube videos. And like somehow, it's been broken for months and it's been fixed. And I would like to think that that is like, you know, people are like, where, where's all the
（你知道的）98% 的確定性，它就在那裡執行，你知道的，但每隔一段時間就會有一些崩潰、一些狀況或一些中斷。我不知道你們兩個是否有人在 GitHub Pages 上執行過任何東西，但 GitHub Pages——或者只是 GitHub 本身——變得非常不可靠，因為每個人都在做我正在做的事，也就是免費運算，對吧？就像 GitHub Actions，我從來不知道怎麼寫 GitHub Action 程式碼，我甚至不知道它的語言。我想它只是 YAML。但你可以設定 Cron 排程任務和一大堆東西。但現在因為每個人都在這麼做，他們的伺服器正在崩潰。
benefits of AI. I'd like to think that every time something gets slowly fixed now, it's AI that's not humans. It's AI that's like going to slowly make software. That's my utopic view of the future is all these issues where we're turning off, you're trying to get Chromecast work. Oh, God, help us all. You know, Chromecast,
所以大約每四天一次，我在 GitHub Actions 上執行的 Cron 排程任務就會失敗。我就會想：好吧，我們又把伺服器搞掛了。但這就像在某個時候，他們會進行設定，使得（你知道的）就像亞馬遜和 AWS 搞懂彈性運算並擴展規模一樣——這些軟體也會發生同樣的事情，每當出現問題時，事情就會自動被分拆出去，然後它們會問：問題是什麼？它們會立即診斷出問題。它們不僅會修復問題，還會強化系統，就像是：好吧，這裡到底出了什麼問題？而且我有這樣一個——我知道這是一個烏托邦式的（你知道的，也許是超人類主義的）對軟體未來的看法，但甚至
you know, the most finicky piece. I just want the TV to play on the TV, you know? It's just crazy. You know, a world that that would work. And I imagine in the future we're just going to click one button, it's going to work. And people are going to be like, wow, remember the days when like we had to get Connor and he spent 20 minutes and he just said, you know what, screw it.
——我發誓上帝我一定是在投射，YouTube 上有一個小錯誤，我有個小加速功能，捷徑是 Shift（你知道的）逗號和 Shift 句號來放慢和加快影片的速度。但如果你曾經按暫停然後再播放，它就會重設為 1，這雖然不是世界末日，但有點煩人，因為它就像 Shift 然後通常需要再按四次才能達到 2.0 倍速，這基本上是我觀看所有 YouTube 影片的方式。不知怎的，這個問題壞了好幾個月，然後它被修復了。我願意相信那是——你知道的，人們會說：AI 的好處都在哪裡？我願意相信，現在每當有東西被慢慢修復時，都是 AI 而不是人類。是 AI 在慢慢修復軟體。這是我對未來的烏托邦式看法，所有我們關閉的這些問題——你試圖讓 Chromecast 運作。噢，上帝，拯救我們大家吧。你知道的，Chromecast，
We're not going to watch Disney Plus. We can't figure it out to get it to work. I guess we'll just watch Netflix again because admittedly, Netflix does seem to work much better than all the other alternatives. Anyways, yeah, that's my utopic vision, is that all the problems that humans have baked in to all these software code bases are slowly going to, like, heal over time. It's just a matter of, you got these.
你知道的，最難搞的東西。我只是想要電視在電視上播放，你知道的？這簡直瘋了。一個能運作的世界。我能想像在未來我們只需要點擊一個按鈕，它就能運作。人們會說：哇，還記得我們必須找康納（Connor），而他花了 20 分鐘，最後卻說：你知道嗎，去他的。
The agents, as we've been discussing all episode, they're just human. And so thus. Why would we, why should we suspect that we will live in a perfect software world free? It's exactly what Sean just described, though. It's like you get one to monitor the other one, and they're doing it 24-7. It's not, you know, one person's working, and then they asynchronously check a GitHub issue. It's just like. I know I've tried using this.
我們不看 Disney Plus 了。我們搞不定它。我想我們還是回去看 Netflix 吧，因為不可否認的是，Netflix 似乎確實比所有其他替代方案運作得好得多。不管怎樣，是的，這就是我的烏托邦願景，即人類在所有這些軟體程式碼庫中植入的所有問題，隨著時間的推移都會慢慢地——癒合。這只是一個問題，你擁有這些
I've had it end up in in loops where they're monitoring each other, and they never agree on success. And I've seen this fall down, too. What are your thoughts, John? What are your thoughts? Do you think it's possible or is Bryce, is there always going to be a flaw in the system? I think, you know, systems like this at scale, you're always going to find either like the specifications are self-contradictory at some point or the system just becomes chaotic at some point. And, you know, I think LLMs will have a better, at some point we'll do a better job at doing things like detecting those cases. but whether or not they can fix them is an interesting problem.
代理，正如我們整集一直在討論的那樣，它們只是人類。因此——為什麼我們、我們為什麼要懷疑我們將會生活在一個沒有完美軟體的自由世界中？不過，這正是尚剛才所描述的那樣。這就像你讓一個去監督另一個，而且它們是 24 小時不間斷地在做這件事。這不是（你知道的）一個人在工作，然後他們非同步地檢查一個 GitHub 問題。這就像是——我知道我嘗試過使用這個。
But I tend to agree with you, which is the system is much more repeatable and scalable with the LLMs, right? I can write down the rules and it can go do the thing and it can analyze way more software and way more quickly than people can. And the challenge there is I think right now most people, the way they're using AI is they're creating the same crappy code that they would have written, like most people in the industry, faster. The problem is expanding right now. But I also share your utopian vision of that can be fixed, that, you know, cloud code or equivalent can ship with a solid engineering process baked in.
我曾讓它陷入迴圈中，它們互相監督，卻從未對成功達成一致。我也見過這種情況崩潰。你有什麼看法，約翰？你有什麼看法？你認為這可能嗎？還是說布萊斯，系統中永遠都會存在缺陷？我認為，你知道的，這種規模的系統，你總是會發現要麼是規格在某個時間點相互矛盾，要麼是系統在某個時間點變得混亂。而且，你知道的，我認為大型語言模型會在某個時間點做得更好，在偵測這些情況方面做得更好，但它們是否能夠修復這些情況是一個有趣的問題。
It's got a superpower skill, which is probably the closest thing that Anthropics ships to an engineering process. But like I said, I think we're in, we're in 1.0 territory on these kinds of systems. And so I expect at the right things are going in a year from now, we'll be having the conversation about, you know, whatever, cloud code, software engineer app, and how amazing is that? And like I said, I think we'll get to the point as an industry, we'll start to be able to measure the effectiveness of process, which is a very expensive and difficult thing to do with
但我傾向於同意你的看法，也就是有了大型語言模型，系統變得更具可重複性和可擴展性，對吧？我可以寫下規則，它就可以去執行，而且它分析軟體的速度和數量可以比人類多得多。而其中的挑戰在於，我認為現在大多數人使用 AI 的方式，是把他們本來會寫的那種爛程式碼——就像業內大多數人一樣——以更快的速度創造出來。問題目前正在擴大。但我也分享你的烏托邦願景，即這可以被修復，你知道的，CloudCode 或同類產品可以附帶一套內建的穩固工程流程。
people. Yeah. Right. And so that will get to the point where the system can iterate much faster and potentially start iterating on its own, right? It can run its own experiments. Yeah. That's, I think, the next frontier, the recursive systems or the auto-rearchive systems or the
它擁有一個超能力技能，這可能是 Anthropic 發布的產品中最接近工程流程的東西。但就像我說的，我認為我們正處於這些系統的 1.0 領地，所以我預期對的事情正在發生，一年後我們將會談論（你知道的）無論什麼 CloudCode、軟體工程師應用程式，以及那是多麼神奇。而且就像我說的，我認為作為一個產業，我們將會達到這樣一個點：我們將開始能夠衡量流程的有效性，這對人類來說是一件非常昂貴且困難的事情。
auto-rearche, I think that's what everybody's starting to make a big shift to. So, yeah. In my story about the agent hallucinating and the other agent catching it, I just had this thought in the back of my head, which is so how much longer until the LLM, what I see scroll by is, is, you know, I ask this person to go get me, you know, this additional resource that I need to keep running. And they didn't come back.
對吧。所以這將使系統能夠以快得多的速度迭代，並有可能開始自主迭代，對吧？它可以執行自己的實驗。對。我認為這是下一個前沿，遞歸系統或自動重新架構系統，或
So when they do come back, I'm going to kill them and assign this task to somebody else. you definitely like that's yeah i definitely probably not the killing part hopefully not you know fingers crossed we get the alignment problem figured out but definitely like i i don't know i i live at the whatever the edge of this tech and so my wife always reminds me you know most people aren't seeing the things you're seeing they're not thinking but just like i think like you know self-driving is better than humans and just like so much of this stuff is going to become like these AIs, they're just better. You know, it's just safer.
自動重新架構，我認為這是每個人都開始做出巨大轉變的方向。所以，是的。關於代理產生幻覺而另一個代理抓住它的故事，我腦海中突然閃過一個想法，那就是：離大型語言模型——我看到滾動過去的是——你知道的，我要求這個人去幫我拿（你知道的）我繼續執行所需的這項額外資源。而他們沒有回來。
You know, they're better at writing code with like, even if maybe on the first shot, it has as much bugs, as many bugs. It's able to, you know, fix them and iron them out a lot faster. And, and yeah, it's a very exciting future. We'll keep our fingers crossed. We know that you have to go in like 10 minutes or so. Maybe on a, because we're probably, definitely,
所以當他們回來時，我要殺了他們，並把這個任務指派給其他人。你絕對——就像那是——是的，我絕對——可能不是殺人部分，希望不是（手指交叉）我們能把對齊問題搞定，但絕對就像——我不知道——我生活在這個技術的前沿，所以我太太總是提醒我，你知道的，大多數人並沒有看到你看到的那些東西，他們沒有在思考——但我認為（你知道的）自動駕駛比人類更好，而且很多這樣的事情將會變成——這些 AI，它們就是更好。你知道的，就是更安全。
going to release this might be our longest episode ever as episode 300. might not be as edited as heavily, but, you know, it's a trade-off. You know, the listener gets a almost two-hour podcast with Sean Parent. And maybe as a final question, you know, for the younger listeners out there, of which I know we have quite a few that are potentially either in school or, you know, about to leave school, you know, we talked about Dave and how he's retired and now he's focusing on music. And we talked about how you've still got lots of exciting stuff to work on.
你知道的，它們更擅長編寫程式碼——即使可能在第一次嘗試時，它有那麼多漏洞、那麼多的漏洞。它能夠（你知道的）修復它們並更快地把它們熨平。而且，是的，這是一個非常令人興奮的未來。我們拭目以待。我們知道你大約 10 分鐘後必須離開。也許在一個——因為我們可能、絕對
But by the time, you know, the 20 years rolls around. and AI is better than everybody at everything. You're also going to retire. And you mentioned a few other folks. I happen to know a guy at Nvidia that said if this is really what engineering is going to become, he has no interest in it. And I won't call the individual out, but said that he's got multiple children, one of which is in music school.
但等到 20 年过去，人工智能在所有事情上都比所有人强的时候，你也要退休了。你提到了其他几个人。我刚好认识英伟达的一个人，他说如果工程学真的变成这样，他将毫无兴趣。我不会点出这个人的名字，但他提到自己有好几个孩子，其中一个正在音乐学校上学。
And he thinks that it's possible that that is the big, what do you call it? Like the best outlook career-wise is for that student, where the other ones are in a more traditional STEM. I don't want to give away too much information. but that listener knows we're talking about them right now. What is the either advice? If you were in school right now watching this, like are you just panicking?
而且他认为，这可能是那个巨大的——你叫它什么来着？——就职业发展前景而言，对那个学生来说是最好的，而其他人则在走更传统的STEM路线。我不想透露太多信息，但那个听众现在就知道我们在说他们。那么你有什么建议呢？如果你现在在学校里听到这个，你会不会感到恐慌？
Like what would you now tell a younger version of you that isn't going to be retiring in the next 20 years or at least not forcibly, I hope. I hope there will be still jobs for some people. What would you, what would your advice or wisdom be? Yeah, in the crazy times that we're currently living through and we will continue to live through. Yeah.
就像你会对一个不会在未来20年内退休、或者至少不是被迫退休（我希望如此）的年轻版本的自己说些什么？我希望某些人以后依然能有工作。你会给出什么建议或智慧？是的，在我们目前正在经历、并将继续经历的疯狂时代里。是的。
You know, my advice is always, the same for any student, which is the primary thing you can do in school is learn how to learn. And so that you can adapt to change. And change right now is coming more rapidly than never before. And so that's the key thing, right? Keep reading, learn the fundamentals, get a broad education. Don't just specialize in one thing, right? I spend a little time in the philosophy department in the school of arts and not just in your STEM career.
你知道，我的建议对任何学生来说都是一样的，那就是你在学校能做的最主要的事情就是学会如何学习。这样你才能适应变化。而现在的变化比以往任何时候都要快。所以这是关键所在，对吧？坚持阅读，掌握基础知识，接受广泛的教育。不要只专注于一件事，对吧？在文学院的哲学系花点时间，而不仅仅局限于你的STEM职业生涯。
So that would be my advice. And then the other thing would be to start thinking about society and policy and get involved on that end. You know, the Industrial Revolution was a huge change from a societal end and a standpoint. And I think AI is going to be a bigger change. And I think just saying, you know, I don't want it, I don't like it, is not a productive stance. So getting involved with what are meaningful policies for how this can be rolled out and start to think about what is the role of people in society where we are no longer the most intelligent thing on the planet, you know, build the future the way you want to see it. You know, right now, I think our politicians and leaders are woefully ill-equipped. I don't think they have any idea of what's coming.
所以这就是我的建议。然后另一件事是开始思考社会和政策，并参与到这方面的工作中去。你知道，工业革命从社会层面和角度来看是一个巨大的改变。我认为人工智能将是一个更大的改变。而且我认为只是说“我不要它，我不喜欢它”并不是一个建设性的立场。因此，去参与制定关于这项技术如何推出的有意义的政策，并开始思考当人类不再是地球上最聪明的生物时，我们在社会中的角色是什么——用你希望看到的方式去构建未来。你知道，现在我认为我们的政治家和领导人严重缺乏准备。我认为他们根本不知道即将发生什么。
I think we just have a small glimpse of what's coming. Damn. Any books? I mean, now, I love to ask. I've been getting most of my book recommendations from Boris Churney because he's read all the sci-fi of like, you know, that deals with these potential utopic or dystopic futures. or even also too, I would love to read a book that, like, details the industrial revolution from, like, different points of view because there have been these shifts in society, but I'm not a historian. And also, I haven't been a big reader of history other than, like, a few biographies here and there.
我觉得我们只是对即将到来的未来有了短暂的一瞥。天哪。有什么书推荐吗？我是说，现在我喜欢问这个。我一直在从鲍里斯·丘尔尼（Boris Churney）那里获取大部分图书推荐，因为他读过所有处理这些潜在乌托邦或反乌托邦未来的科幻小说。或者甚至，我也很想读一本从不同角度详细描述工业革命的书，因为社会经历过这些转变，但我不是历史学家。而且除了零星几本传记之外，我以前也不是一个历史书的大读者。
So I'm not sure. What would you book recommendations as well for people that want to get started on that journey? Boy, this is horrible because everything I've been reading lately has been papers. I don't know. I don't have a good book recommendation. but I will think about that. So next time he asks me, next time you have me on the podcast
所以我不确定。对于想开始这段旅程的人，你有什么书推荐吗？天哪，这太糟糕了，因为我最近读的全部都是论文。我不知道。我没有什么好的书推荐。但我会考虑的。所以下次他问我，下次你邀请我上播客的时候
already make a good book recommendation. Okay, we will. Maybe if you, because this will go out on Friday, if you think about them before Friday, we can put them in the show notes. Because I am, there seems to be like a lack of book.
我一定能推荐一本好书。好的，我们会的。也许如果你能在周五之前想好——因为这期节目会在周五发布——我们可以把它放进节目简介里。因为我发现，似乎有些缺乏这方面的书籍。
Like there's a ton of sci-fi books, but there's not a ton that, like, deal with what's going on because this has happened so quickly. And like, obviously, AI comes up time and time again, but not, not, probably there are a bunch of books out there. there. I'm less well-read than I should be probably at my age, more well-read than the average
就像有很多科幻小说，但没有太多真正处理当前正在发生的事情的书，因为这一切发生得太快了。很显然，人工智能一次又一次地被提起，但可能——也许外面有很多这样的书。我读的书可能比我这个年纪的人应该读的少一些，比普通人读得多一些
person, but that still doesn't say much because there's a lot of people in society. Bryce, do you have book recommendations? I know you've read the Asimov books. Yeah, that's been the last thing I've read recently. I've been so, I've been so busy with everything that's happening right now. I haven't read any books in a while. Yeah. I could recommend one, but it's like, it's like 5% an erotica novel, which is not great. Well, nice. Now you got to recommend it. But it's monetized if it's accelerando. I'm in the middle of three books, one parenting book, one like, I don't know, self-help,
但这也说明不了什么，因为社会上有很多人。布莱斯，你有什么书推荐吗？我知道你读过阿西莫夫的书。是的，那是我最近读的最后一类书。我太忙了，最近发生的各种事情让我应接不暇。我有一段时间没看书了。是的。我可以推荐一本，但它大概有5%是色情小说，这其实不太好。好吧，不错。现在你非推荐不可了。不过如果它是《加速》（Accelerando）的话，那倒是有版税可拿。我正同时看着三本书，一本是育儿书，一本是某种自助书
you know, better mental health book. And then this book that's like AI, it's Accelerondo by Neil Strauss, which is on a lot of these lists. If you ask AI, like, oh, I read, you know, this book, that book, this book, what next? It almost always gets recommended. The AI did not warn me, though, which is not that I'm against reading about erotica or like, you know, what do you call it, like 50 Shades of Great kind of stuff. But I would just, you know, every time it starts during this book.
你知道，关于改善心理健康的。然后还有一本关于人工智能的书，是尼尔·斯特劳斯的《加速》（Accelerando），很多这类书单上都有它。如果你问人工智能：“哦，我读了这本书、那本书、另一本书，接下来该读什么？”它几乎总是会推荐这本。不过人工智能并没有警告我，倒不是说我反对读色情小说，或者像什么《五十度灰》那种类型的。我只是觉得，每次在这本书里……
Because I'm just trying to consume all of the novels about like, you know, AI take off and, you know, like cloud uploading your brain and stuff. Trying to get ready, you know. I feel like that's the closest thing you can get to an education in the future of AI because, you know, there's nothing out there really that is like addressing this exact moment. All right. Should we let you go, Sean? Is there any last things you want to say?
因为我只是想吸收所有关于人工智能腾飞、将大脑上传到云端之类的小说。你知道，试着做好准备。我觉得这是你能找到的、最接近人工智能未来教育的东西，因为外面真的没有什么东西在探讨这个确切的时刻。好了，我们该让你走了，肖恩？你还有什么最后的话要说吗？
Thank you so much for taking two hours of your day. I mean, this has been fantastic. I mean, there's so many times you were talking. And then I was like, oh, that's the cold open. I was like, oh, my God, that's the cold open. Oh, my, how am I going to get? I'm going to have like four different cold opens for this show. We got to say something about episode 300.
非常感谢你抽出两个小时的时间。我是说，这太棒了。有很多次你在说话的时候，我都心想：“哦，那是冷场开白（cold open）。”我当时想：“天哪，那是冷场开白。天哪，我该怎么弄？我这期节目得有四种不同的冷场开白了。”我们得说点关于第300期节目的事。
Yeah. So, like, congrats on hitting 300 on the podcast here. This is great. And thanks for having me on for the 300th episode. How many years has this podcast been around? Is it like six? Well, 52 weeks in a year. So it's coming up on six years in November.
对。所以，祝贺这里的播客迎来第300期。这太棒了。也谢谢你邀请我来参加第300期的录制。这个播客已经存在多少年了？有六年了吗？嗯，一年有52周。所以到11月份就快满六年了。
We're so old. Yeah, the key is the key of consistency is really chunking these up into smaller things because it's so much easier to record once and get like three episodes than it is to like what CTP guests did for that many years in a row. Every single episode, like recording was a single episode. Although, you know, I have. been thinking about like future plans if coding's not a thing and maybe full time talking to people is not a bad you know i don't make any money from this right now but i could pivot and try to and uh you know like i said connecting with people it's i would love to do this on a more regular
我们太老了。是的，关键在于，保持一致性的关键确实是将这些内容切成更小的片段，因为录制一次就能产出三集节目，要比像以前C++嘉宾连续好几年那样容易得多。每一集，录制都只是一集。尽管你知道，我也一直在考虑未来的计划，如果编程不再吃香，也许全职跟人交流也不是个坏主意。你知道，我目前从这上面赚不到钱，但我可以转型尝试一下，而且……就像我说的，与人连接，我很乐意更定期地做这件事
basis and the problem is is i don't like ads so you got to find a different way and i don't want it really to charge people for this stuff so if you don't like ads and you don't like charging people it's kind of hard to make a living off. Yep. All right, well, we will let you go. Thank you so much, Sean. We will do this again. And also, too, are you wearing the CPVCon shirt? Are you going to conferences or speaking? Is there the last, if people want to find you places? Is there places they can do that? No current plans. You know, invite me right somewhere. All right. You heard it conference organizers. Invite, Sean. He'll be there.
问题在于我不喜欢广告，所以你得找一种不同的方式，而且我真的不想为此向人们收费。所以如果你既不喜欢广告又不想向人们收费，要以此谋生就有点困难了。是的。好吧，那我们就放你走吧。非常感谢你，肖恩。我们还会再做这个的。另外，你穿着CPVCon的T恤吗？你要去参加会议或演讲吗？如果人们想找到你，最后还有什么地方可以找到你吗？目前没有计划。你知道的，邀请我去某个地方就行了。好吧。会议组织者们，你们听到了。邀请肖恩吧。他会去的。
And if we hear from you, we'll announce it to make sure that wherever you're going, ADSP listeners can know where to find you. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
如果我们收到你的消息，我们会宣布它，以确保无论你去哪里，ADSP的听众都能找到你。请务必查看节目简介，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 网站上，都可以找到我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及可以留下你的想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。